foreign
hey everyone welcome to Simply learn
today we will be learning the project
management skill course we will begin
this video by talking about what project
management is Project planning how can
it be done using Excel cost quality
communication and other forms of
management the best project managing
tools how you can prepare for the PMP
exam the role of a project manager
interview questions and much more by the
time you are done you will be well
versed with some of the most important
Concepts in project management for this
training with me we have a specialist
Chandra Mr and ishan together they will
take you through these different topics
so let's start by answering our first
question what is project management so
before we begin make sure to subscribe
to our YouTube channel and don't forget
to hit that Bell icon so that you can
never miss an update from Simply learn
hi welcome to project management
tutorial from Simply learn I am Chandra
Mr a professional consultant and coach
in best practices related to project
management and IT service management
today as part of this tutorial we are
going to learn the basic understanding
about the project management and the
required knowledge for a project manager
to become successful in managing
projects so as part of this tutorial we
are going to look at what is project
management what is Project components of
project management Project Life Cycle
key Focus areas in project management
job roles in project management and
project management certifications so
what is project management now as
defined in pmis pmbok project management
is application of knowledge skills tools
and techniques to project activities to
meet project requirements so every
project will have an objective to
accomplish similarly the objective of
project management is to make the final
deliverables in a finite time and budget
this involves having clear understanding
about the deliverables of the project
require resources for the project
resource in terms of Human Resources
Technical Resources Financial Resources
Etc project managers should have a full
picture of those aspects we can call it
project manager should have a full view
about a project and what is that this
project has to accomplish that objective
should be clear so as part of project
management the six constraints which
project manager should look at are scope
time quality cost risk and resources so
each of these areas has very important
role to play in project management the
clarity in scope the clarity in terms of
schedule within which the project has to
be delivered the cost what it incurs to
that particular project once it is
finalized one cannot vary one cannot
change without any proper approvals
similar to that we have quality manage
specifications what are defined project
output will be accordingly achieved risk
every project is taken up for a specific
reason by organization so organization
should assess the risk associated with
the project and similarly as project
progresses various different risks has
to be identified like Risk related to
project management risk related to
technology area risk related to
resources risk related to financial
things so broadly risk management plays
a very important role so there will be
something called contingency reserve
kept for a identified risk above the
cost what is estimated phase
deliverables from the project so every
projects require resources resources may
be in terms of Human Resources Financial
Resources technology resources
environmental resources so all these
resources are used to produce the output
of the project so these resources has to
be managed with a sufficient
optimization and standardizations
required now let us understand the
definition of a project so what is a
project PMI defines a project as a
temporary Endeavor undertaken to create
a unique product service or result the
temporary nature of a project indicates
that a project has a definite beginning
and end so when I say product unique
product it means every output it may be
similar products you are producing with
the same features and functionality but
the output of every project is unique
because it is unique in terms of all the
six constraints what we just discussed
now now when I say product it is very
easy for us to visualize it may be a
desktop it may be a laptop it may be a
car it may be a machine Etc but how do I
visualize a service now Project's output
is a service now it is it's about
building a capability a project by
through a project a capability can be
built to ensure Services can be provided
that's what the output of project is
service for example if I think about a
taxi services for providing a taxi
services I need a mobile app I need back
C I need a server I need a data center
so all these are various different
products and services here service
example can be internet service so
combination of all the services and
products builds the capability for an
organizations who can provide the taxi
services so building that capability we
say it is an output of a particular
project which is called service
similarly results can be Improvement of
something Improvement in customer
satisfaction increase in some specific
objectives or specific results need to
be achieved in performance perspective
so output of every project will be
unique product or a service or a result
this we need to clearly understand so
when we say there is a definite
beginning and end every project starts
at a certain point in time and ends at
certain point in time so it has a
definite beginning and end that is the
reason it is temporary in nature it is
not an ongoing business activity right
so every project will have a life cycle
a beginning and end so when it starts
till end until the result or a service
or a product which comes as an output of
a project project lifecycle is not ended
so interestingly in a product life cycle
or in a service life cycle you come
across many project life cycles so one
Project Life Cycle means one project is
initiated to introduce a product or
Services next project or initiated would
be to enhance the capability of a
service or a product next project
initiated after some time is to optimize
something similarly at the end of the
product life cycle project is initiated
to return that product or services so in
a given product life cycle there will be
multiple Project Life Cycle so what is
involved in the Project Life Cycle it
involves five areas five groups we can
call it as so initiation planning
execution monitoring and closure so when
I say initiation it's up all about
understanding what is Project giving the
basic understanding of the project
collating the details and having key
stake holders identified once that is
done one will move towards planning so
here in the initiation it is very
clearly one has to understand is Project
is worthwhile of doing so one has to
check the feasibility one has to measure
that particular investment is making
sense and then confirm yes it makes
sense to invest now next planning as we
have a basic understanding of yes this
project has to be done and a discussion
with the key stakeholders have happened
now that moves towards planning now in
planning one will understand the project
in entirety if it is a waterfall
approach one has to have a clear
articulation of entire project a
comprehensive details holistic approach
now if you go if you're going in a
project in a agile way of approach now
in this planning you may have a big
skeleton as you go in each of the
acceleration you may go deep dive into
detailed planning if it is a agile
approach so planning provides you the
clear Insight towards what needs to be
done in this project project how it has
to be done and what are the results
which can be achieved out of that
particular project so this involves
making that a clear blueprint of an
project objectives what we are supposed
to achieve so this will become a
reference point throughout the Project
Life Cycle then execution as you have a
blueprint of the project as the
direction of that project is set
detailing of the project has been made
one will go ahead and expand
implementing it so execution phase
involves the allocation of resources and
making the deliverables as required you
acquire resources you configure a
resource you ensure right resources are
acquired if it is human resource one has
to educate the human resource with the
project required knowledge or details or
one has to provide that assignment in
such a way that skills of that
individuals what they should have is
acquired by those individuals so that
deliverables can happen and they needs
to be managed the entire team needs to
be managed for that a clear structure
has to be created similarly when you do
technology resource perspective those
components has to be tested configured
then integrated again tested for
unchecked the performances so Collective
action of this results in a deliverable
during the execution so as the
deliverables are happening in the
execution it is quite obvious project
manager has to monitor review control
that particular deliverable and also the
processes tools resources used during
the project even those needs to be
monitored so that they are complaining
to the defined processes so during
monitoring there may be a deviation one
can found during monitoring there may be
the project is running the way it is
required so in this monitoring phase it
involves an action from project manager
to Monitor and control the work of the
project so comparing with the blueprint
of plan what is accomplished what is
created during the planning phase of
this project and as the execution
happens monitoring and control is
monitoring it and checking is that
active it is what is being done is
according to the plan or not similarly
the deliverables which comes as an
output of your projects are tested
thoroughly whether those have a specific
features and functionality and are they
functioning the way it is required now
project has to be delivered to the scope
what is defined it should not go beyond
that or below that similarly the
schedule what is made for the project
within that schedule project deliverable
system accomplished within the cost what
is budgeted for the project so during
the project your project manager may
find there are certain deviations which
are occurred there are additional
challenges which has come in so for this
reason one has to ensure continued
monitoring as the execution happens and
identify those deviation and ensure
Whenever there is a deviation there is a
correction Whenever there is an
additional things coming in that needs
to be considered carefully whether that
need to be involved as part of this
deliverable or should be taken it
separately so this requires lot of
conversation with all the stakeholders
of the project during the entire Project
Life Cycle especially during planning
execution monitoring and control since
they are not the one which is happening
in sequence so planning can also come
back again where there is something
which you may require to modify so may
require to have a change in the
blueprint Itself by adding that new
change which is coming in so you go back
to planning so planning execution
monitoring and control are going hand in
hand so that project deliverables are
happening as needed similarly all the
process or instructions all those
templates what is given are used one is
complying to those requirement it is
very important and project is done
within the scope schedule and time and
the quality metrics defined then as the
completion of the project happens as the
monitoring and control says yes
deliverable has happened according to
the requirement then the project moves
to the closure the closure may be
closure of a specific project phase a
milestone deliverable or a phrasal
deliverable or it can be a deliverable
at the end of the project which is the
ultimate deliverable so processes in
closing has to be triggered Whenever
there is end of the phase Whenever there
is a deliverable to conclude and also at
the end of the project to conclude the
entire project so during the closure one
has to ensure capturing all the details
in terms of what is accomplished against
what is defined what went wrong what
went well what is a learning one has to
take to the next level or the next phase
or to the next project and at the same
time a sign off has to be obtained
formally and everything should be
summarized and have a good handshake
with the project stakeholder mainly a
business or customer and also
disseminating of Team means you will
dismantle the entire team and send them
back to their specific units or
specialization and they may get assigned
to new project or if it is a functional
they can go back to their functions to
do their functional activities so that
was about entire Project Life Cycle what
happens now while doing this I mentioned
there are six constraints that is scope
schedule cost quality risk and resources
so keeping these in mind one has to
ensure project is successful in all
aspects so to become successful there
are few key areas which has to be looked
at so first six key areas are scope
schedule cost quality resources and
stakeholders now let us look at the
scope what the scope means scope is
about what needs to be delivered what is
in scope what is out of the scope so
this refers to all those deliverable
scope all those activity scope basically
we speak about two things one is product
scope and project scope product scope is
all about ensuring the features
functionality of products are well
defined and understood and signed off
and while delivering that product that
is tested against those defined features
and functionalities whereas projects go
focus on all the activities needs to be
done all those templates which has to be
used all the process which has to be
complied with all that skills which is
required to be applied so it is going as
defined so by doing this activities
which is defined as part of project
scope the result the deliverable will
come out which will be in line with the
deliverables features and functionality
which is defined as part of product
scope it is very important to ensure
entire projects happens within this
particular scope there should not be any
deviations from this schedule
perspective for that specifications what
we defined for a product and a project
so these needs to be done in a specific
point in time means in a specific
schedule there will be start time and
time right so one has to plan how long a
project would take and what are the
deliverables should happen in what
sequence what activities are required to
accomplish this so all these needs to be
understood so while performing the
schedule management one has to look at a
specific deliverable at a specific point
in time by applying a specific set of
activities required so this will tell
you the duration of the project this
will provide you the sequence of project
this will also help you to understand
the dependency between one task to
another task this will also help you to
understand how the deliverables
happening in what sequence which helps
in prioritizing your deliverables third
is cost so as we know to do any project
it is very essential to ensure project
happens within that budget so project
cost is estimated initially then that
estimated cost will be checked checked
in terms of is the assumptions
considerations are right or wrong is
that really so much of a monetary
resources are required for the project
and then after understanding the
justification and obtaining the clarity
budget is I mean monetary resources are
allocated and confirmed approved then to
become a budget that will be a cost
Baseline so these estimation allocation
of budget once it happens that will
become a base and any deviations from
that cannot happen so easily so any
deviations because of additional of
scope that can be handled through change
management but idealistic scenario the
cost should not escalate or come down
organization can also set certain
tolerances at the project level
considering various different scenarios
like scenario of risks scenario of
something which deviated from the
deliverable so to what extent it can
deviate that tolerance will also be set
at the economic or monetary value
perspective that is about cost
now quality as we know quality is a very
important area which ensures the project
is delivered in time with all the
specifications defined by using all the
methods means by following all the
processes work instructions templates
and delivering as needed where it
enables the project to monitor it easily
so basically the requirement of
compliance and standardization and
optimization is to ensure everyone
follows the same steps do the activity
so what quality management focus is to
ensure the intended objectives of a
projects are achieved already there is a
definition done in terms of various
different practices or processes needs
to be followed similarly specification
of each of the products are defined and
from that there should not be any
deviation so quality management should
focus on ensuring those activities are
done as defined those deliverables are
done according to the specifications
what is different it is very important
that way so for that there is a layer of
quality management should be a layer of
quality management where auditing or
control activities are initiated
periodically so that any deviations can
be seen easily and remember a project
manager can become cannot become part of
quality management like project manager
cannot audit project manager should have
a team or take the help of a team who
can able to do mostly the one which is
who is not part of the project is always
better resources now as I mentioned
earlier every project need resources it
may be human resources it may be
technology resources it may be any other
resources which are required to do the
project so organization acquires
resources configured and then deployed
for example in a project you acquire a
server you configure a server you deploy
a server technology resource human
resource is onboarded recruited project
induction is given then at the same time
the skills and capabilities of
individuals are according to the
requirement of project that needs to be
ensured and what needs to be delivered
and how it has to be delivered should be
cleared to the particular human resource
so looking at all the aspects of
resources to acquire to build and manage
it is very important to look at the
resource management so this will help in
carrying out a specific task in a
project in the best possible manner so
interestingly when I say human resource
always there is a possibility that a
conflict can occur so when I say
conflict conflict of interest may be in
terms of what the individuals has to do
conflict in terms of the preferences in
terms of solutions what they are looking
at conflict in terms of using resources
different opinions different preferences
various reasons conflict and come across
so it is very important to project
manager to understand this dynamics of
human resources and manage this
conflicts project manager cannot shy
away from handling conflicts project
manager has to hone and resolve those
conflicts in the favor of project not in
the favor of any individuals so there
are various techniques to look at
resolving conflicts so that is like
compromising problem solving smoothening
accommodating
so whichever helps for that project
scenario for the project objectives that
needs to be applied that technique has
to be taken up so here the resolution is
not at the specific individual's
preference it is with the objective of
other projects as any impact what kind
of impact positive or negative if it is
negative no that's not the direction the
direction should be ensuring project
gets that value through this conflict
resolution so project manager should own
it it's an accountability of a project
manager then as the human resources are
acquired there are five stages Team
Dynamics are involved so one has to
bring them then educate them about a
project as a education on the project
happens one has to go and do the job on
floor that needs to be observed means
one has to manage by looking at it and
any corrections is dividend that needs
to be guided so it is very Dynamic thing
when it comes to Human Resources
similarly in technology resources
standardization there is no ambiguity as
such but Resources with the right
configurations should be acquired that
is very important the next stakeholders
so who can be stakeholders every project
will have a stakeholder who are internal
and external to the project so the
internal stakeholders are those who are
part of the project who are part of the
organization who are part of the
customer organization or part of
supplier organization a competition to
my business means my organization's
business all this we can call it as a
stakeholders now every stakeholders will
have a specific interest a power an
ability to influence now through their
position through their distance from the
project they will get impacted at the
same time they will also impact the
project similarly they influence and
they get influenced because of the
project so a project manager should
identify all the stakeholders and
understand this what is the kind of
stakeholder is this in terms of power in
terms of legitimacy in terms of
influence in terms of impact after
understanding that there should be
strategy for handling the stakeholders
how am I going to engage with these
stakeholders it is very important and
accordingly the engagement should happen
and then stakeholder engagement should
resolve in the favor of projects again
so if it is a customer customer should
get that inputs required through review
or periodic updates and the engagement
required with the customer so that
customer is having up-to-date
information about the project if it is a
team continued monitoring and control
and ensuring team delivers the results
what is required so focus of a
stakeholder should be in such a way that
your strategy should enable project to
become successful and get a proper
response from the stakeholder means a
supporting engagement so next few key
Focus areas to mention is communication
risk procurement critical success
factors deliverables and work breakdown
so this list is not exhaustive as we
deep dive into project I think you can
just keep listing the key Focus areas
more than this but whatever we have
indicated are the minimum which needs to
be looked at so when I say communication
communication is basically a
conversation exchange of message which
happens between two entities now
whenever we communicate it is necessary
to understand that it has to happen with
two individuals or two entities there
should be sender there should be
receiver in the absence of receiver if
sending is happening that communication
doesn't make any sense there should be a
receiver and there should be an
acknowledgment from the receiver now
this is one of the most ignored area in
many of the projects even the
communication happens more often more
frequently but what people face
difficulty in realizing that as they
communicate generally informally
formally they just take those for
granted now when you identify the
stakeholder one has to understand what
is the communication requirement for
those stakeholders what is that
communication why is that communication
what is the content of that
communication how frequently we should
do that interactions or Communications
in intent of that particular
communication what is the expected
action or response from that
communication all this needs to be very
very clear and this can be articulated
it has to be articulated so one it is
articulated once there is a picture in
terms of what kind of communication has
to happen it is quite obvious there
should not be any deviation from the
agreed Communications requirements and
whenever there is a need of change to
the communication requirements from the
stakeholders that needs to be updated
for this one has to have a stakeholders
identified so stakeholder management and
communication are very closely linked
and Associated a engagement with the
stakeholder will become successful with
an effective communication approaches
next is risk so every project which is
undertaken by organization that will
have certain amount of risk which
organization will evaluate similarly
within the Project Life Cycle lot of
risk comes up which would have certain
impact to the project now risk refers to
by definition an uncertain event it has
an uncertainty an event which is
uncertain and when it occurs it will
have an impact on the project positively
or negatively now current scenario in
everywhere on the projects What You
observe closely people tend to look at
the risk which are threats that is
negative only but they fail to recognize
the risks which are opportunities the
positive risks so another gap which we
see when do the risk management is that
is done in the initial phase of the
project as the project is kicked off
someone will do the risk assessment have
a list of risk identified but
unfortunately there is no
categorizations for that risk and how is
that going to impact the project that is
not clear thirdly risk management or
list of risk are created only once it is
not done repeatedly so risk
identification and Analysis and
assessment of that risk has to be done
throughout the life cycle of your
project reason being the risk which
looks as in high impact when project is
initiated as the project progresses the
impact levels will vary Maybe the middle
of the project the impact may be very
high or low so likewise the impacts of
the risk will vary throughout the
Project Life Cycle it may be positive it
may be negative so as you identify the
stakeholder throughout the Project Life
Cycle as I said that is also a dynamic I
cannot just have a list of stakeholders
and I keep it as it is I need to update
that also regularly risk identification
assessment and Analysis should also be
done regularly periodically so that one
will have a clear understanding about is
that risk still valid is that risk is
there still or not what is the level of
variations in terms of impact of the
risks so this Clarity will be there so
that neces organization or project
manager can get ready to face those
risks if it is a negative risk
definitely you should have a mitigation
or avoidance or acceptance whatever the
mitigation plan you have to eliminate
the negative impact of the risk when it
occurs okay if it is a positive risk
it's quite obvious one has to take the
advantage of that one has to enhance
exploit share a positive risk so that
organization is benefited further
procurement so whenever a project is
initiated whenever a project is taken up
the organization who is doing the
project cannot create everything cannot
develop everything in that Project Life
Cycle so organization would take a
decision make a decision stating that
some of the deliverables we make
ourselves some of the products we make
ourselves some of the products we
purchase some of the services we
purchase so to purchase that has to
happen from a specific supplier you
cannot go with every supplier you should
evaluate the suppliers qualify the
suppliers and then select onboard the
supplier and then get the services or
products supplied by that particular
supplier so while doing this one has to
understand what type of Contracting they
need to enter with so three types of
contracts we speak basically one is
about a Cost Plus contract where cost is
fully known to the project manager and
to the organization so apart from known
cost a fee will be paid to the supplier
another one is fixed price where project
manager or the organization who is
awarding that contract to A supplier
will not know what is the cost instead
it is a fixed price but important here
is the scope of work needs to be clearly
articulated and defined another type of
Contracting can be time and material
where the billing will happen based on
the amount of time one is spent on that
particular a higher resource or onboard
resource entertainment material basis
and what is that effort that resource
has been put based on that building will
happen so three types of contracts
depending on the different scenarios of
the project will be signed with the
contractor however before doing that it
is very essential to identify those
suppliers sign off with them and monitor
and manage them so if deliverables are
not there it is very essential to look
at the termination who has to terminate
otherwise one has to ensure instead of
uh terminating should be able to put
some effort to educate them also so that
they come up to the mark So project is
benefited so depending on what needs to
be done that call has to be taken on a
regular basis then critical success
factor so for every project there should
be an articulation of critical success
factor So based on that one can confirm
yes project has achieved its objectives
our project has not achieved its
objectives so key critical success
factor should be supported through the
metrics key performance indicators so
key performance indicators provide those
metrics to say critical success factor
is achieved for example if I to become
successful in an exam critical success
factories scoring or passing the
examination or let me say to pass the
examination key performance indicator is
scoring 60 and above so critical success
factor for me to get promoted is to pass
in this particular exam so to pass in
this exam minimum I should score is 60
percent that is kpi passing in the exam
that is critical success factor so how
will I measure that success factor is
kpi so every project which it produces a
specific product or Services by using a
specific resources and each of these the
resources the processes the templates
the deliverables all these needs to be
measured on a continual basis so there
are critical success factors defined and
those are measured by defining kpis to
that critical success factors so
basically critical success factor
provides the Insight towards what needs
to be measured and when you measure what
should be the focus and to achieve those
critical success factors the indicators
key performance indicators when you
measure yes the moment you achieve that
your CSF is achieved next deliverables
so deliverables are those which comes as
an output of the project right it may be
a product it may be a service it may be
a result so this refers to the output
within the scope of a project so there
can be one or more deliverables within a
single project so these deliverables may
be the items that are to be sent
externally to a customer or a
stakeholder so every deliverable will
have a defined scope will have a defined
specification so those derivatables has
to be measured tested and one has to
confirm yes this deliverable is
performing as we are intended to have
the performance accordingly the decision
will happen should we accept this
particular deliverable or not if there
any deviation that has to go back for
correction so that's the reason we have
monitoring and control all the control
processes like control quality focused
on the product straight whether it has
achieved that results or not is that
functional as needed or not one has to
ensure these deliverables has all those
features and functionalities only then
that can be handed over to the
respective stakeholder customer or
operation whoever the stakeholder it is
next is work breakdown structure so when
we say work breakdown structure when I
look at a specific piece of product or
services and have a bigger picture I
cannot even visualize the various
different components various different
actions involved in achieving that
bigger deliverable so if I say a car so
I can think of a body external I can
think of a mirror on that body I can
think of a glass in the front side as
well as the back side and also I can
think of Interiors like seat then
accelerator steering dashboard only
second visualize but since I am not a
technology expert relating to car can I
visualize all those parts which are
working inside for car to move like
engine the battery assembly I don't know
what to say further so all these can be
visualized by an expert so every product
or services should be broken down into
multiple pieces I'm not saying go and
break that product I am saying that
product will have multiple components
which are involved those needs to be
segregated for example if I say cars
exteriors cars interior so cars
exteriors external items you can see
whatever you visualize body body
structure mirror mirror assembly
headlights then tires so likewise
whatever I can visualize I will make it
as a line items under the exterior so
under for example under a mirror mirror
I can speak about mirror glass mirror
cap mirror pedestal and mirror assembly
where it moves where you can move the
mirror so these are the various
components involved in a mirror so I
need to ensure by breaking down the
product into multiple levels the Depots
decomposing it to multiple levels I can
able to visualize the product very
clearly what is there in detail so once
I have the details I will articulate
those what is that particular work down
element is product breakdown element is
then I will look at what skills and
capabilities required for that product
and I will assign the resources
accordingly so once activities resources
everything is assigned automatically
this will become our breakdown structure
further after creating our breakdown
structure one will go on sequence the
activity look at sequencing will happen
based on in what priority deliverable
should happen What order deliverable
should happen then once the sequencing
is done it will be checked to see
whether anything can be optimized
anything can be done in such a way that
smooth flow of the project can happen
there is no dependencies which will make
project to delay like as the flow
happens smoothly so you would find the
various techniques like critical path
method Network diagramming critical
chain method so all these are used the
floats of an activities are checked then
leads and lags of the activities the
relationship between activities so
accordingly full visualization in terms
of how the project will flow and how in
what order the deliverables are
happening can very easily visualized so
that is the reason first activity is to
do the product breakdown which would
result in work background structure so
those are the points till now whatever I
mentioned are the basic understanding
one should have about a project and
project management so as you deep dive
into various best practices like PMP by
PMI prince2 by axelos scrum Master agile
scrum Master similarly you have
certified scrum master so many agile
practices so when you look at any of the
best practices that will tell you
clearly articulate what should be the
practice for you to adopt and adapt that
practices so that your project can
become successful so any of those
approach you touch upon all those refers
to these basic things in the absence of
these basic things none of those best
practices discusses the project
management now typically in the industry
there are a lot of job roles to the
project management which we have seen so
based on that this information is
captured here on various job roles in a
project management so some of them are
like project manager senior project
manager Project Lead resource manager
pmo that is project management office
analyst steering committee member so not
necessarily all the project management
roles are limited to this so these are
the roles which commonly you see and we
are trying to capture that to give the
Insight right when I say project manager
the project manager is the owner one has
to take an accountability for the
project right so project managers takes
the project according to the plan and
plays a lead role in all the steps of
the project management right so
responsibilities would be managing
reviewing and prioritizing the task
wherever necessary looking after risk
management stakeholder management and
project communication management some of
the salary what we found while we were
doing the survey the success ratio of a
project depends majorly on the project
manager so the demand for project
manager is rapidly increasing in the
market so accordingly uh seventy five
thousand four seven four per year that
is a USD in INR it is fifteen hundred
thousand so this is what the salary of
an approximation what was found next
role we look at senior project manager
where senior project manager is ahead of
the overall project management plan the
role demands in-depth knowledge of all
the project aspects on a specific on the
specifics of the project the
responsibilities would be planning and
coordinating complex projects visiting
project sites to check progress and
handle complex issues so salary looks
like one not four thousand dollars per
year here twenty ninety two thousand INR
per year so the role of senior project
manager is one of the highest paying
roles in the industry as we have seen
having several allowances and bonuses
because of the criticality involved in
the project and the accountability level
of that particular individuals in the
organization next role Project Lead so
project leads are the one who leads the
people throughout the project and
provide them with all the information
required throughout so responsibilities
involve motivating the team when it's
taking care of their needs and paying
attention to what they feel ordering or
controlling the project team since the
project lead has more freedom than the
project manager salary Project Lead
makes sure that project gives the best
possible outcome and is hence the demand
for the project lead in a company never
reduces so in USD 82 000 per year
whereas in INR it is one million to
sixty nine thousand per year next roll I
will look at on resource manager so
resource manager is the human resource
needed to make the project success right
so one has to manage those resources
responsibility involved assigning the
right people to the right projects at
the right time managing employees
currently and determining hiring needs
depending on the Project's requirements
so salary would be around 64 000 USD
which comes around 966 794 in INR
project management office analyst for
this role the project management office
analyst works with pmo means project
management office and does not look at
the project or manage the project
directly instead does most of the data
driven work which required for a project
to have our project to get supported by
that so that project managers will have
better Insight analyzing and
interpreting the data concerning the
project figuring out the future risks to
the project finding new ways to advance
the idea of the project management so
salary would be one or six thousand two
fifty three per year in USD whereas 449
thousands 337 in INR per year so
steering committee member so the
steering committee members are the
members who do not work on the project
themselves they are there to help the
project manager like providing inputs
during the development of a project
advising on the budget and evaluating
the project strategies taking regular
feedbacks on the project managers and
asking necessary questions so salary
would be around a 68 000 497 dollars per
year so those were the various rules and
that is not that list is not an
exhaustive list various different roles
we come across but these are the basic
roles which is seen in the industry
these roles are being recruited now
there are various project management
certifications which are offered as I
mentioned earlier so those
certifications are PMP that is project
management professional from PMI agile
certified practitioner that is PMI ACP
again from PMI then certified associate
in project management so difference
between capm and PMP is like capm would
act as a basic level of certification
for those who does not have a sufficient
project experience project management
experience whereas pmps for those was
some project management experience
similarly PMI sap is the one who is
aspiring to look at agility in project
management and they can go for it
certified scrum Master yes it is a scrum
Master certificate which will explain
the role of a scrum master in detail
similarly prints to a certification from
axolos which also speak about all the
aspects of the project what we discussed
and provides the framework for project
management axillos also provides
Princeton certification in agile also
agile prints to a certification so we
will look at each one of this certain
details which are required for us to
know so project management professional
as I mentioned is most acknowledged and
value the certificate value what it
carries which has resulted to the
certified Professionals in landing up in
highest paid jobs in the world so
certified managers gets 20 percent more
salary than the average salary so to
take up an examination one has to go
through the formal training of 35 hours
that is one of the prerequisites and
there should be some experience of 4 500
hours of project managing project by
Leading Rarities activities of a project
and once the person becomes eligible
with that prerequisites personal become
register in the pmi's website becomes
member and then go for exam Nation so
examination fee for PMP would be 4.5
dollars for the members who are
registered with PMI and for those who
are not registered as a member with BMI
it is 555 the duration of the
examination is four hours and the number
of questions will be 200 which are
multiple choice questions so each each
questions carries one marks there is no
negative score now prerequisites one has
to have 4 500 hours directing and
leading the projects that experience has
to be filled in while filling the
application if a person is a bachelor
degree holder and along with the 35
contactors of PMI PM education now
prerequisites for the one who is not a
graduate who may be high school or
diplomo is 7 500 hours of directing and
leading projects 35 hours of PM
education so those are the prerequisites
before one will go on appear for
examination so once an individual passes
PMP examination that certificate is
valid for three years so now after three
years if the person has place to keep
the certificate continued they need to
produce 60 pdus professional development
units which has to be acquired during
those three years how to acquire one has
to go through additional learning one
has to contribute towards project
management knowledge base so those needs
to be evidenced and then renewable fee
has to be paid and certificate has to be
renewed then agile certified
practitioner as we saw for PMP here
agile certified practitioner
demonstrates that one has relevant
experience in education to handle and
Lead agile projects the organization has
started shifting towards agile as we
know in today's industry which makes
this certification fast growing in the
world so examination fee would be 435
dollars for PMI members 495 for non-pmi
members duration is three hours and
multiple choice questions 120 questions
prerequisites is 2 000 hours project
management experience with 1000 500
hours agile experience and 21 contact
hours of agile practices so maintenance
30 videos are required for every three
years and after paying the renewal fee
that can be renewed now certified
associate in project management so here
this is an entry level certificate of
PMI especially for those people who has
less project experience it intends to
demonstrate fundamental knowledge
terminologies and processes of effective
project management so examination fee
would be dollar 225 for PMI members
whereas 300 dollars for non-members of
PMI so duration of examination is three
hours and examination will have 150
multiple choice questions so
prerequisites someone who has secondary
diploma 23 contact hours of PM education
is enough there is no experience of
doing the project is required as we saw
in PMP so maintenance is again three
years someone who need to continue this
certification as to retake the
examination every three years next
certified scrum master so certified
scrum Master is an entry level
certification that helps support
professionals to begin as the scrum
practitioners is one of the most sought
after certifications as other after this
one can get the designation of certified
scrum Master which is offered by scrum
Alliance so examination fee which will
change team to time which is not
revealed so one has to approach the
training organization where they will
get trained on certified scrum master so
duration of examination is 60 minutes
and pattern would be 16 hours 2 days of
training and 50 multiple choice
questions after that particular two days
of train then prerequisite is done for
maintaining this credentials so one has
to ensure it has renewed every two years
then project in controlled environment
that is prince2 so prince2 is a method
which is effective mostly from the base
of UK all the organizations who are from
UK region prefer prints to certification
and it is as popular as any other
project management certifications like
PMP so examination fee would vary from
900 dollars to thousand dollars
depending on where exactly you're taking
the examination and certification will
happen at two levels one is at
Foundation level and other one is
practitioner so in Foundation it is 60
Questions multiple choice and in
practitioner it's 68 questions now 60
questions or 68 questions each carries
one marks for correct answer any wrong
answer there will not be any negative
scoring one has to score 55 percent to
clear the examination so prerequisites
for Princeton Foundation is none whereas
prince2 Foundation is a prerequisite for
friends to practitioner examination so
to maintain the certificate one has to
achieve 20 cpts every year continued
professional development so now project
as part of this project planning we
would be trying to understand what is
uh project planning project planning
fundamentals
then why project planning tools for
project planning and then basic project
planning steps
so let us look at a case a scenario what
happens if there is no planning in place
right so
if you look at a scenario where one of
the
Executives in the organization who is in
the project is tensed and what is the
reason the person is intensity if you go
and query that Acquire that person
so he says have issues in estimating the
budget now when we say planning uh
planning is not just about budget
planning is beyond budget
so which involves uh many things like a
schedule which is time the scope which
means the deliverables as well as the
resources and other things what we need
to do the project and to the and to
understand what is the deliverables in
requirement perspective similarly we
speak about quality we speak about risk
we speak about stakeholders procurement
so likewise the planning is bigger than
just a budget but however in this case
we're just looking at a scenario where
estimating the budget has become an
issue so what could be the reason that
has become an issue
right that might be because uh I you
haven't planned for project properly so
which requires a detailed understanding
or proper understanding of whatever we
are doing
so so let me tell you how you can make
sure it doesn't happen again with the
help of project planning this is what
the response from a experienced
Personnel in the organization who is
into pmo or who is into project
management practices on regular basis
who has a significant amount of
experience so that is the reason he
could able to point out let us look at
the planning so only then we can able to
have a proper understanding about what
needs to be done and what is there
exactly we need to focus on
so now what is Project planning now when
we look at a project as a whole when we
visualize project as a whole
planning is one of the important part
now if I look at pmi's framework we
speak about 49 project management
processes until PM box extradition it
was defined
so now out of 49 processes 24 processes
are dedicated for planning which means
almost 50 percent of the processes are
there for planning and that is the only
area where you have the processes in all
the knowledge areas so we speak about 10
knowledge areas like integration
um then scope management then so cost
Management schedule management risk
management quality management
communication management stakeholder
management procurement management
Resource Management so in each of these
knowledge areas we have the processes
when it comes to planning but when I say
I'm going to initiate the project I'm
going to execute the project I don't see
processes in all the knowledge areas and
it has its own reason will not get into
that however the important Point what we
need to have an understanding is
planning plays such a significant and
important role where uh majority of the
clarity you obtain you have to obtain
during the planning so we will have this
confusion so when I go with the detailed
planning of something
I may end up in having some changes in
between means Whenever there is an
uncertainty in the project uncertainty
is huge now there you cannot have a
detailed planning for entire project but
you may require to have the detailed
planning for the extent it is visible to
you right to the extent it is clearly
visible to you visible to you as a
project manager then you can able to
execute that part of it and get into
elaborating further and then understand
the next part of the project if you are
going as as agile way of doing the
projects but however in either of the
cases whether you are going with
predictive approach of the project or
you are going with the Adaptive approach
of the project in either cases planning
is must and it plays very important role
so many a times we only look at the
deliverables part of it you only look at
some processes relating to executing
part of it we miss out in terms of risk
we miss out in terms of quality maybe we
miss out in terms of analyzing on the
effort and resources so these will
actually create issues as you progress
in the project and you may find
difficult in taking the project to the
directions required to the objective
what needs to be accomplished so first
thing we should have a Clarity is any
project when organization takes up
organization takes up the project for a
reason maybe because of solving certain
problem or improving or enhancing
certain performances or enhancing
certain features functionalities in the
product in the particular product or
services
or wanted to introduce some new product
or Services into the market likewise
there are many reasons organization
would have to take up the project and
when organization takes up the project
we should keep in mind organization
takes up the project for a reason
business reason now as a project manager
I need not worry about Revenue but I may
require to have a proper understanding
of why the project is taken up what is
the reason the project is taken up and
what is that organization is trying to
accomplish out of it when as a project
manager I have the clarity
it helps me to take the project in a
specific Direction so we may not have
any we should not have any ambiguity or
not having the clarity
and start as a project manager one has
to obtain the clarity and to that
context to accomplish to have everything
set aligned to the directions we may
required to plan so everything we do in
the project should be aligned to what we
are doing however in planning everything
should be visible must only then you can
able to bring that alignment if it is
not available during the planning if we
don't if we are not considered during
the planning then obviously we may find
difficulty in taking things into that
required alignment or accomplishing that
objective because your execution will be
based on your planning and all that you
Monitor and control will be based on
what is defined during the planning
similarly uh
when you close before closure you test
check whether everything is accomplished
again that is what is defined in the
planning we may have something defined
before a project is taken up but the
justification app is there for sure but
for aligning to that you do planning so
everything should be in line and what
intense organization wanted to
accomplish that needs to be achieved and
that requires a proper planning so
looking at a project in entirety
right in a project in entirety uh
project may have multiple stages or
phases project may have multiple
packages to deliver project will have
multiple Developers
so each of these would consider
initiating planning executing monitoring
and controlling and closure
now at each level so if I look at a
project level yes definitely it is there
if I look at the stage or phase level
yes it is there if you look at a
specific deliverables yes it is there at
every level we plan
so since our interest our focus of this
particular session is to look at the
importance of planning project planning
let us focus on planning part of it but
however I'll give you some overview
of the framework projectman will
framework how it would look like so when
I say initiate what should I initiate so
initially the initiation happens from
business itself as I mentioned already
for accomplishing certain objectives
through that trigger project is taken up
a business case would be created a
project Charter will be created and the
project Charter will bend it over to the
project manager
while creating this project Charter that
would be considering all those details
which is mentioned in the agreement or
the business case and then that it will
provide an entire summary of the project
what needs to be accomplished what is
that organization aiming is aiming to
accomplish through this project
so having that Clarity project manager
would take up and connect with
stakeholders and then identify all the
stakeholders discuss with them bring in
smes have a team structure and then
create a detailed planning if it is
predictive or a skeleton plan if it is
agile approach I mean adaptive kind of
thing so once the planning is done it's
all about execution so as a project
manager a project manager as an
individual may not be doing the and so
on of that particular project execution
however the project manager would be
involved actively in terms of ensuring
all those resources are available all
those processes are complied with then
all the stakeholders are connected
updated deliverables are happening as
per the plan so project managers should
see that it is happening and get their
things done so in many project
management session I keep telling people
keep asking me these questions
specifically the project manager should
have a subject matter expertise
answer is yes not to the extent where
project management will go sit and do
the configuration but however project
manager should know what question to ask
what exactly the team is speaking about
project manager should able to visualize
that so meaning project manager should
do the groundwork
uh immediately while you get into
planets in entirety understand from the
smes understand from the industry
experts or you do your own groundwork to
know what exactly it is speak to
business and then only then during the
execution you know exactly what is that
output can be expected and accordingly
you do monitoring and controlling so
from execution to monitoring and
controlling so why would a monitoring
and controlling so as the deliverables
comes out as the features has been
introduced
so there should be metrics to measure
there should be methods to measure those
metrics and each of those metrics
critical success factors or key
performance indicators
one should be able to analyze and
understand interpret so it should not
look like just a number I'm working to
accomplish that number it should not
look like that
so accomplishing that number should
result in accomplishing the intended
objective so that is a kind of
understanding team should also have so
through monitoring and controlling one
should align the entire thing by giving
the picture snapshot how things are
going in execution so which project
manager should actively involve here as
well to understand but this is based on
what is being planned
then once it is confirmed everything is
accomplished or achieved according to
the plan then that can be declared for
closing further it can be an acceptance
so without having any confirmation in
monitoring and controlling that
everything is accomplished things cannot
move towards closure
so once it is done in market and
controlling once the validation is done
then only the acceptance can happen so
once the acceptance is done formality of
handing over and handing over the
product or feature putting into
production
having formal sign off from the
customers happens in closure
but Acceptance in terms of features
delivered or it is according to what we
have planned those are checked in
monitoring and control and formalized in
closure
so let us move towards planning what
exactly happens in planning so we get
into defining objectives
so explaining the scope now speaking
about defining objectives and explaining
scope
now uh oh sorry so now uh
uh I told business has taken up a
project with an intent that will have a
direction now to accomplish that
particular objective the planning should
have its own set of objectives
considered uh to Allah in alignment with
the objective what is different it is a
context the direction what is set so
those objectives should be clear to the
team it is not just about defining those
needs to be explained to the team so
team should be uh well aware of what
exactly they are going to accomplish by
doing this then explaining the scope
now Scope when you say one should
visualize
both deliverable as well as what I
should do to deliver it for example if I
am
making a pot for example a clay pot a
cake Clay Pot would be having certain
shape size color thickness of the wall
of that part so this is a specification
of pot
that is the output that is a deliverable
and that itself will have the scope so
clay pot will have the scope and to
accomplish that Clay Pot as an output I
need the clay mix I need to have that to
wheel which is used I need to have a
person who know that Pottery activity to
make that pot and all that resources
materials what is required to do it now
one is the scope of that output itself
which you can call it as product scope
other one is scope of the activities the
processes the resources what we do so
the scope of output we can call it as a
product scope and the scope of what we
want to accomplish that results we can
call it as project scope so we cannot go
otherwear we cannot Define the project
scope and say that I am going to
accomplish this deliverable no so first
we need to understand what is the output
what is that requirement we are going to
fulfill have the clarity have the
description how the picture how exactly
it looks like once it is completed and
then you come back and Define what
process I need to do this what resources
I need and what effort I require what
budget I need who are the stakeholders
for this all the picture will come only
when you have the clarity about what is
that I am going to deliver from the
project so products go as well as
projects go
then scheduling task
now I said project scope product scope
we understood what is to be delivered
now project Scope when I say we have a
set of activities we have a set of
resources
we need the budget we need to have an
involvement of stakeholders now all of
these should happen at a specific point
in time everything cannot be done in a
specific one time right so it needs to
be sequenced it has to be understood
what kind of sequence it is so how am I
going to uh do this when am I doing
going to do this when is very important
so each of this activity what I need to
carry out to accomplish that particular
results I need to have the schedule
defined clearly
so when so some activities may happen in
parallel some happen in sequence for
example if I take a wall in a
construction project if I take a wall
after doing the plastering of the wall
only I can do the curing
I cannot do the wall finishing as well
as curing of the same wall at the same
time it cannot be in parallel whereas I
can construct a wall one meanwhile
parallel I can have a construction of
other wall or curing over the wall I can
do but all all a if I say the plastering
of that wall and curing the top wall I
cannot change the sequence it should be
in sequence only whereas parallel if I
am constructing another wall on the
other side and curing that is possible
which can be done in parallel
so that we need to visualize when we
schedule when we set that sequencing of
that activities we may require to have a
proper understanding of that
that is about scheduling tasks or
activities
then generating progress reports
now it is very important anything and
everything we do we may require to
capture you may require to analyze you
may require to review We may require to
see what can be improved we were
required to look at what can be
optimized and we need to understand what
is going good what is not going good How
can we overcome that something which is
not going good How can we further
improve on what is that we are doing
good so we need to analyze that so for
for that first and must is to understand
how is it now we wanted to have this to
happen in certain way is it happening
that way
or is it happening in something some
other way what is it exactly it is
happening so we may require to capture
the details so while planning I said we
may require to consider critical success
factors key performance indicators
metrics to measure
but we should know what does this matrix
mean
how am I going to Analyze This
so if I say uh 80 percent of utilization
means what
what is my interpretation should I keep
quiet or should I do something about it
we should understand that so now I am
supposed to accomplish something in 25
minutes I did that in 30 minutes what
does it signifies five minutes extra I
took is it okay
so it depends on what deliverable what
activity how important is the
deliverable so that understanding should
have so those things has to be analyzed
by capturing those details as a report
and reviewing that significantly uh
thoroughly along with the team as well
as the stakeholders relevant
stakeholders and then the way you
represent that particular report may
have the variation because when I use
that metrics to discuss and review with
the team the objective will be different
whereas when I do it with my boss or my
customer or some other stakeholder the
objective may be different what they
want will be different
so I cannot uh get into the detail what
I discussed with the team similar
details I cannot discuss with the other
stakeholders it depends who are the
stakeholders with whom I am going to
discuss this and what is that I am going
to present and how are we going to uh to
pick this and what exactly we're going
to learn what is that we are going to do
further from this so project will have a
specific objectives and directions
clearly mentioned but uh to take it in
that direction and understanding whether
it is in direction or not or are we
required to do some changes to bring it
back if there is a deviation all this
needs to be the clarity needs to be
obtained
now what are those uh planning
fundamentals we are required to have
Clarity in terms of what is that we need
to consider while planning very clearly
so here determining scope cost and
resources
so the process of scope cost and
resources I said 10 knowledge areas I
mentioned earlier
so in that scope cost and resources so
definitely three important areas which
helps in estimating time required to
complete the project the number of
people needed and with what skill set
now this is one tricky thing so now it
is not just about human resource it's
about skill set now in that skill set
again you speak about to what extent is
it at expert level or the basic or
intermediate what is that exactly to
what extent what is expected out of that
role
all this depends on deliverables what we
need to do right so the understanding of
this one can have by having the work
breakdown structure
now many times I have seen whenever I
use this term of breakdown structure
people straight away get into uh
writing the list of activities and then
organizing them in certain order
that is not the way to do the breakdown
structure so now whenever we start doing
or breakdown structure first thing one
needs to focus on is the on the
deliverable
now for example uh if I take a bottle as
a deliverable
a simple water bottle now water bottle
if as a user if I look at it it just
looks like a plastic one transparent one
with the cap water filled inside that's
how it looks like for me as a user but
for someone who is creating it for
someone who is making it
I need to hire certain activities
processes which are required equipment
resources which are required to create
that bottle right so what does the what
we will have as a deliverable it will
have that body
right the main water body it will have a
cap and along with the cap there will be
a ring which will just use to seal that
particular cap
then it is not plain bottle right so you
will have a wrapper around it that is
another deliverable if you want to do
the breakdown of this bottle I would say
cap as one part cap ringa is another
part maybe body is another part body
wrapper is another part now further I
can have a description
so cab will have a specific color cap
will have a specific size right and
specific circumference radius thickness
similar in the capturing then water
bottle if you take again that
transparency level kind of material of
that bottle and its specifications the
design you want to have on the model
it's a ring design or some s design
whatever as you look at the bottle or a
plain one and then base of the bottle
neck of the water
then comes the wrapper which you put it
across the sticker part of it what is
that the sticker is all about what is
the combination what is the design of
the sticker
so likewise I will break down so bottle
looked very simple so same thing if you
visualize for a car as an example so I
can say car Interiors car exteriors and
intelligence of the car has three main
parts breakdown Parts similarly then
Interiors if I speak about I can speak
about under Interiors the seat the gear
lever the steering right the floor then
the dashboard I can have that breakdown
and further and inside there is a mirror
as well right so if I speak about
further if I break down if I take a seat
as an example so see it as a base it has
a backside one addressed then the seat
Mount like as many things comes up so I
keep breaking down like this until
logically I cannot subdivide now
similarly if I take exteriors I can take
body Bonnet then next rear view mirror
outside likewise I can do intelligence
if I take like engine system or
intelligent AC system like because I can
have the bring down
let us take a
Car rear view mirror as an example if I
break it down further
right similarly I can speak about mirror
motor likewise now can I further
subdivide this mirror glass mirror cap I
cannot do so I'll stop there
for each of the breakdown items I keep
breaking down to the extent where
logically I cannot subdivide
it doesn't make uh to subdivide further
now what I will do the work breakdown
structure the technique we call it as
decomposition
we do top down as as shown in the
picture here
top top down it is going so now hansi
has a stop down structure breakdown
structure which required as a product
breakdown structure once I have the
product breakdown structure then I'll go
bottom up now what will I do bottom most
item I will take for example mirror
glass I will take as an example
so what is the thickness of the glass
definitely rear view mirrors are convex
mirrors what is that convex
specification of that mirror
what is that thickness of that mirror
what is the size and shape of that
mirror glass
I'm speaking of about glass only I'm not
untouched about a cap I have not even
touched about Motorola till now I'm just
speaking about the glass alone mirror
and glass alone and once I have a
specification to that mirror glass to
that I would see what resource I need
for it
what effort is involved to make the
gloves
right and what is the budget
what is the risk involved what is that
quantity I need to make
so all these details I am putting at
that level it's a lower level
then I'll move to the cap I'll speak
about all of this relating to the cap I
do estimation of that then I'll speak
about the Mount Mirror Mount then I'll
speak about the motor likewise from
bottom up I will do it for every element
and keep consolidating upwards
as I consulted upwards at the ultimate
consolidation level top level I will
have overall budget I will have overall
schedule or effort I will have overall
resources require Total Resource
required however what are the activities
involved in consolidation likewise have
a consolidation of course
so once we have this consolidation we
can easily look at the effort involved
the budget involved and further we can
optimize
so that's where work breakdown structure
is very essential so now whenever I
speak about our breakdown structure a
simple question which comes up common
sense question not the wrong one asking
okay it is very good if I know what is
the deliverable clearly
so in today's environment we're speaking
more and more about
um
adaptive in nature the projects with
adaptive in nature a lot of changes
keeps coming in people speak about
becoming a child Etc now what is
happening here how do I create work
breakdown structure
nothing to worry so now if you take an
example of a bank introducing a mobile
app for mobile banking let us give an
assumption now what happens here
even though there are a lot of Mobile
Banking applications available we are
used to it Bank cannot release the
full-fledged product
simply because the investment
perspective enabling the bank and
consumers to use that app if I take me
as an example till now I never used the
mobile banking application of the bank
with whom I have the account
they have motivated me many times they
never went I never used it I never
thought of using it I'm using third
party application and integrating
everything
then is it does it mean that I don't
like my banking application banking
application of the bank with whom I have
an account answer is it is not the
answer something like I've never wanted
to test it I did not find time to look
at it I'm not motivated enough to look
at it the existing one is okay with my
kind of thing so if that happens the
investment of bank will be waste right
so they need to promote motivate their
customers to use the application and see
what kind of transaction is happening in
that account and only then they can able
to invest further they have to study
take the feedback from their consumers
and then move forward
so there we have the agility changes
keeps coming in prioritization changes
so here as a mobile banking application
I know what components are involved
which is an inward only priorities will
be changing
in this case I will not have an issue of
creating work breakdown structure
but in a scenario where I am doing some
research I am introducing new product to
the market unique new product of the
market which I don't have any Clarity
orbital function but still to some
extent I will have the clarity about the
product
so whatever the extent of clarity you
will have you should do this breakdown
so that you can able to track them so as
you bring in new features to it where it
doesn't uh where it is not mentioned in
the WBS structure you can keep adding to
this WBA structure so that pictorially
you have something in front of you so
tracking will become simpler and easier
later
so that's about our breakdown structure
[Music]
so identification of problem
right so variety of techniques such as
conducting surveys or meetings are used
to collect information to assess problem
so it's not just about uh problem it's
all about opportunity also
right so problem management when I said
usually we do proactively we do
reactively so proactive problem
management is always foreseeing what can
happen if a container like this as it is
what happens if this happens as what if
conditions will analyze and then we take
action that is proactive problem
management reactive if something has
occurred to resolve it we'll get into
that so in either case in either of the
cases identification of problem is very
important
so problem resolution can help in terms
of financing and boosting something as
part of your organization's
functionalities
So within the project there will be
something which needs to be addressed so
this needs to be analyzed so planning
helps in analyzing this proactively
you're not reactive to anything so you
are proactive a business may be reactive
to some extent in that case also you
will can be proactive in terms of
problem management
so there may be multiple Problems single
problem some problems where you may
require to have an attention need to be
paid immediately
so one interesting part is whenever I
ask someone what is your understanding
about problem they say issue they speak
about some failure
so they were they find difficult to link
the term problem to actual meaning of
the problem itself
so when I say issue when I say
occurrence of something that we can call
it as an event or issue or incident that
cannot be a problem
so for occurrence of this even for
occurrence of that incident for
occurrence of that issue
there may be certain trigger root cause
that root cause can be called less
problem so that correct understanding we
should have whenever we say
identification of problem
something failed for example internet
failed in this training that is not a
problem
internet failed means it's an incident
occurred why internet failed
as I go deeper and try to understand why
it failed then we will see the cause
that is the problem that if you address
we can eliminate many uh ways improve
the availability of the incident and
reduce the number of incidents related
to internet not available
so that's what the problem is the
problem doesn't come in operations or
business as usual we will find such
things in the project also so to address
the problem sometimes we take up the
project so which we need to have a
proper Clarity but what is that problem
we are trying to address but remember
any project what we take up introduces
change to the environment
problem resolution if I say that
resolution itself is a change happening
to the environment
if I bring in a new structure in the
place where it is an empty land then
that new structure is introduced to that
environment likewise every project
introduces change so in a way a change
project management is change management
that we should keep in mind always
then identification of stakeholders now
as I take up a project
when I have a project Charter as a
project manager I would have a specific
deliverables specific
objectives to accomplish but who will be
there with me
who can give you the proper Clarity or
requirement so I have to connect with
stakeholders as a project manager first
thing foremost thing which I need to do
is to check who are the stakeholders I
need to connect with the stakeholders I
need to identify the stakeholders
initially I identify the stakeholders
fine but that is not the end
identification of stakeholder is not the
one-time job we need to keep evaluating
on the stakeholders their impact their
influence and influence the project and
impact of project on stakeholders and
this is repetitive thing
reason being the stakeholders who were
there initially when we actually started
the project may not be there
various different reasons there may be
resignations there may be promotions
there will be change of role as part of
that organization's job rotation role
rotation many reasons so we may require
to
keep identifying the stakeholders
re-evaliding the existence of those
stakeholders and then keep updating our
stakeholder register so who can be
stakeholders stakeholder can be an
organization stakeholder can be an
individual stakeholder can be a group of
teams anything so who can influence
impact directly indirectly get
influenced get impacted directly and
indirectly all these are stakeholders so
identify the stakeholders captured them
in the stakeholder register look at what
is their importance we we call it as
something like power interest grid what
is the power of a stakeholder what is
their interest relating to this project
for example if I'm doing an IT project
and if I consider it head as a
stakeholder obviously high in power High
interest because project is related to
iot this it project if I have an HR head
high in power but low interest
if the project is not related to them
for example I am working on a project to
have a network connectivity from my
internet service provider Highline
connectivity as part of our need of
organization HR department or HR it is
least worried about it because their
objective is totally different their
focus will be in a different direction
altogether but high input how to engage
with HR head how to engage with it head
that I can Define based on is power and
interest
so we we have something called Power
interest grid which can be used to put
the stakeholders in each of the grid
part and see how do we engage
so that is very important this may keep
changing based on the position changes
or involvement of new stakeholders time
to time and then accordingly you need to
keep having the change of strategies to
engage with that stakeholders
then defining project objectives
so a plan is made keeping in mind the
various expectation of stakeholder
so very important when I say plan please
remember
organization or customer will have
certain requirement
that will be the scope of the
requirement
to fulfill that requirement you will
have the solution
so solution will have certain
requirements now these solutions to
fulfill the solutions you have the
resources you have the process you have
the facility that is a set of
requirements you will have likewise
requirement is of various different
layers and this requires a specific
alignment
similarly you will have a requirements
at a stakeholders level so unless you
understand and how they connect with
each other if you do not have the
clarity you cannot bring that alignment
required
so that needs to be analyzed carefully
so the successor project entirely
depends on how much of expectation can
the project meet
so by default expectation is achieving
100
accomplishing the expectation hundred
percent
that's where you see the success of the
project
but many times the project may not
achieve everything
in various different reasons but you as
a project manager should not aim for not
achieving everything
if something is going out of the hand
which you cannot control organization
cannot control definitely project
manager will be in touch with project
board or sponsor they are unable to help
you bring things under control obviously
it means it is out of control from the
system itself so such things you cannot
do anything like business acquisition
or you may have some disaster scenarios
many such things comes up because of
which
project may not complete as per the
intent what you have
you may not accomplish those it may
close prematurely
however
which is in your control you should know
and you should move towards the
direction what is required to accomplish
the project and that needs to be updated
to the project board or project sponsor
or pmo whoever is the project governance
Authority project manager should have a
good hand check with them on a regular
basis under review with the team always
right only then you can able to achieve
that objectives and whatever you plan
should consider all of this so here we
speak about risk
right so if something gets deviated why
it will deviate like power failure in
this training I told well power May Fail
that is a risk
so when we run this session if power
fails or Internet fails are we ready to
handle it yes to some extent okay power
goes off
I have the UPS I may say my laptop has
the battery but laptop has the battery
but what about internet
the system should need the power so
obviously we need to have an UPS what if
EPA space can you work beyond that
I don't think so we should work beyond
that
uh that risk remains but probability of
such a currency is very less
right so that we need to analyze
similarly if you speak about something
which we accomplish as part of this
session the object is what we need to
accomplish you may not able to
accomplish a daunted person that
uncertainty remains
so to what extent we can able to
accomplish it what efforts we are
required to put to a completion that's
what we need to analyze and then move
forward and be ready for it
all right
now till now we spoke about what is need
of project planning and what are the
life cycle in life cycle of a project
what are those inward like initiation
planning execution
monitoring and controlling enclosure
then we spoke about some fundamentals of
project planning now why project plan
let us look at that so with proper
planning it will help us in terms of
reducing cost and time instead of saying
reducing cost and time I would say
optimizing cost and time so by
monitoring and then ensuring that things
are under control as we progress so
project planning helps us to accomplish
that
increase employee satisfaction
this is one important thing so we keep
hearing this
happy employee means happy customer
how many times have we heard about it
but in reality is it true
now why do we say happy employee means
happy customer
A Satisfied employee will have more
tendency to contribute to organization
and its success
so how do you keep employees satisfied
it is very subjective
but while doing the planning you may
required to ensure to fulfill or satisfy
the need of the stakeholders involved so
employees one important stakeholder when
I when I have taken up a project
can I have all the employees of
organization satisfied answer is no then
who is attempt why we are referring to
maybe like users who are going to use
this particular product or service the
team members whose driver is involved in
doing this project so visualizing them
and ensuring those particular set of
stakeholders are happy involved
right they contribute and complement to
the project
so focus on engaging team for greater
project performance so unless the team
is motivated you cannot see that they
connect to the users better
so if user's connection is not such not
there with the people who are actually
engaged in the project because as a
project manager you may not go and speak
to all the users right so to test or to
implement or something to show uh to
demonstrate Etc so they should use the
satisfaction Whenever there is a query
from users the team should respond to
them well
for example we took up a project of uh
moving from Windows XP to latest
operating system because Windows XP
support was stopped now users are on
ground the team should go and work with
them because the production will get
impacted if we just take things randomly
it has to be scheduled the schedule
should be communicated a news platform
new things what is coming up there
should be education to the users user
enablement should happen technology is
one part for sure that needs to plan the
procurement has to plan better and you
should do it but when there is no proper
connect with the users and the team
doesn't connect when will team connect
team should have Clarity team should
have the sense of accomplishment only
then they connect better
so bringing such uh what is it
engagement with the customers and users
are is very essential
then implementing quality assurance
the quality experience should happen as
we go we use two terminologies like
quality assurance quality control
so quality assurance focuses on
compliance Credit Insurance focuses on
accomplishing the objective of processes
what is stored what is mentioned doing
it hundred percent uh less deviations of
zero deviations and doing all that
required to be done as per the plan
so since uh planning is if planning
gives the clarity obviously one should
be able to understand that plan and then
take things forward accordingly
then reduces project risk already as I
mentioned risk means uncertainty
uncertainty of occurrence of something
so there are many known things which can
happen for example if I take this
training what are those things which can
go wrong
Mayfield
[Music]
participants May create noise right now
the backend team is not supporting in
time many things can happen
the PPT is not coming up properly the
streaming platform is not working
properly
so all these are uncertainty all these
are working at the moment but they are
uncertain
in what probability let me say five
percent uncertain
are we ready to handle it
so we should make ourselves ready to
handle that uncertainty
so we should have the mitigation plans
we should have a resolution for it
proactively only then we can able to
address it now when can we can can we
have this visibility as this kind of
risks are there in each of this I think
what we are doing through experience
with the involvement of smes with the
involvement of someone who has actually
experienced this journey they can give
that visibility these type of
occurrences can happen relating to this
and also hypothetically you can come up
with what else can happen like for
example with one of my customers when we
were discussing we were supposed to take
over the entire operations from the
existing service provider
so customer came up with one uh
interesting thought what if the existing
service product moves away in hostile
way
so they declare tomorrow we are not
going to support what we do
are you ready to take over that from
Tomorrow itself what is your Readiness
that's very interesting that probability
is very less lesser than one percent
with the business interest of the
entities engaged with with the brand
value what they want to establish nobody
will pull out just like that but however
we cannot ignore that query what
customer has so if we give the
sufficient explanation of our Readiness
hostile except
this is an interesting thing many times
you will have this from the employees if
not the service provider many of your
team members can have that hostile exit
they would have like absconding
scenarios how do you handle that what if
your SM is absconding
what if someone is supposed to deliver
one important thing maybe not a
significant SME but the deliverable
perspective the wellability of the team
members are very important but they are
not available
what will you do so now these kind of
risk factors which needs to be looked at
when I say risk the uncertainty not just
negative always
Risk by default because it is uncertain
uncertainty with certain probability of
occurrence and impact
but
risk doesn't mean only negative it can
be positive also
what can be positive risk I I can have a
overwhelming results I thought it will
achieve 100 it went beyond that
very nice though so like for example
covid-19 pandemic scenario we thought
our productivity would reduce because
everything is working from home instead
productivity increased earlier it used
to be around 70 has become 120 percent
possible that is positive risk
so uncertainty so what in what
perspective in what uh what is the
chance and what probability it can
become an improvement in terms of
productivity when people go working from
home I don't know
maybe I would say two percent possible
probability
it can happen so any uncertainty is risk
it is positive it is negative but we
will have a tendency to look at the
negative part of it because it will have
an impact it will pull away us from what
we are supposed to accomplish that is
the reason we look at negative risk and
analyze them regularly as I spoke about
stakeholder register here also you may
require to establish risk register
but again it is dynamic document if as
you progress in the Project Life Cycle
new risks will get introduced many risks
what you identified initially may not be
there the probability of that impact may
go off
so likewise new risks will get
introduced existing risks may have a
different kind of impacts kind of thing
power failure if you take an example is
a risk for this training what if power
failed when I started the session
entire session is gone impact what if it
goes off at the last five minutes of the
session negligible impact occurrence is
same power going off but when it occurs
the proximity of occurrence also matters
so likewise we may require to keep
evaluating the risks throughout the
Project Life Cycle
identify new risk add it to the list and
then analyze them regularly throughout
the Project Life Cycle that is very
important
then tools for project planning
so definitely memory could have a set of
tools while we plan like WBS thing what
we saw earlier
likewise many tools and techniques we
need as we go through the planning one
is Gantt chart
so Gantt chart we use it for having a
visibly represented schedule
right so uh I think any tool if you see
today including Excel sheet I'm telling
so as an MS project or Primavera or the
Google project sheet or Excel sheet any
kind of project management uh practices
if you see you will see the visual
representation I like the answer
so Gantt chart is one type of you other
one is uh we can think about
Network diagram View
so once you establish a Gantt chart you
can have a network network diagram view
which will show you
when the activity is going to start what
is the sequence of the activity and uh
how they are connected each of the
activities with the dates with the
resources with the activity what needs
to be accomplished right with the color
combination you can say that when it is
starting when it is ending like
similarly we have a critical path method
where you have a tool determining each
of the activities and critical path
means in a given diagram Network diagram
the longest path is called as critical
path
so the duration of the longest path of
the network diagram
will be the duration of the project so
why do we call that as a critical path
we call it as a critical path because
any delay in the critical path will
delay the project itself
[Music]
any delay in the critical path will
delay the project itself that is the
reason we call this critical apathy
so
another one we have like critical chain
method so with critical activities which
essential for accomplish the required
results which has to look at very
carefully see if something that is there
we'll deliver the project so critical
Partners co-share tool for determining
the purpose of project so the project is
on schedule right so from this path and
delay in a critical path will delay the
project
so similarly we have a per chart report
refers to program evaluation review
techniques which will help in analyzing
the task to complete the project and
time required to complete the task we
call this three point estimation while
analyzing this optimistic pessimistic
most likely estimates and accordingly
what would be the estimate of the
duration okay which is in terms of
outline
then a work breakdown structure I guess
we'll do it in detail already so we do
decomposition program
and do profit first and then we go
bottom of adding budget resources
schedules efforts then resource required
then how long it takes in what sequence
sequencing can happen after having the
what background structure like we said
the critical papers as you can see those
we can do only after work we can
structure
computation the project documentation
starts from the point where you create a
project or before that is property
documentation observe agreements
documentation in terms of business case
uh many such documents which are
referred uh while creating a project
Charter project Charter will become a
first document handed over to the
project manager from then project
management
then risk documents
budget motivated schedule part of it
then risk quality procurement related
contraction agreements then register
required all this the stakeholder
registered because many documents which
are
created then record updated
so which are very essential now when
when something called H minus will come
across it says one of the manifesto
buses delivers deliver the features over
documentation now does it mean that we
have no recognitive answer is no
comprehensive documentation that's what
it shows the documentation
to what extent to extend what is
required for that scenario if it is
adaptive obviously the minimum document
or documentation required as you
progress we can keep updating that and
consolidate it whereas a predictive
obviously end-to-end view Theory so
create a comprehensive one group so why
do we not do full-fledged comprehensive
documentation in adaptive simply because
any changes comes up
so we'll have a lot of changes to be
done in the documentation also which
will become TDS X6 but we are not
ignoring commenting right so product
documents helps him uh capture what is
that actually done and what is that we
have planned did we really accomplish
and it will also become evidence so that
we have done it so very important
so this project Concepts would involve
like identifying and meeting the
stakeholders
defining scope then setting and
prioritizing objectives data mining
deliverables then create project
analysis set progress for guidance now
this flow typically like lenient
so I did different meat stakeholders
means you have many stimulus or
understanding the requirements and the
problems and then you keep that
prioritization give it the importance
what is going to do what's next yeah you
should have that top nothing then you
get into uh defining what is the
deliverable is to English it and as you
have a sequence what kind of structure
happens here determining derivables kind
of thing and the sequencing happens when
it comes to Greater schedules and each
of that you may whenever the responses
for all clusters potential
cost resource risk quality so you look
at the risk associated with all of this
and then analytics for all of this and
then have progress Point as we mentioned
and this will be able to think
[Music]
so project scope involves determining
the list of
specific project goals deliverables
budgets and deadlines
then the project scope helps in
establishing boundaries of projectile
responsibility official member
then you will go set and replace
objectives so objectives are set
prioritize once the expectation of
stakeholders become certain
is clear now what is the exact
expectation of statement so this is the
final detail to the initial idea set
that serves as a reference one or
through the project
so then determining deliverables
variables are the reasons why projects
are needed it is one of the most
important to assume those deliverables
so project planning steps of the project
can determine what this deliverables
will be and how will they be delivered
in time
then you create project schedule which
is an outline of different tasks of a
project are supposed to begin and date
so another project will have a beginning
and end very definition for itself says
project starts
project is temporary in nature the
definition of project itself is
temporary hour so it has a bin it may be
of course much it will be for some
matter of years doesn't matter
which creates unique output so running
schedule helps in my progress setting up
the project
our progress reports
so one needs to Identity risks and
consider is important step of protocol
steps to prevent risk from mapping or
limiting their impact should be
considered stakeholders
[Music]
regarding the body progress this can be
done monthly weekly orderly so that all
in one of us and monitor for this and
why is it very important for the support
in detail of it and that needs to be
done and one should have a Clarity very
clear so I think as this explanation
comes up I guess uh it is very clear
one can able to plan the projects within
the budget and do things that quality
that's what he's expressing that's our
explanation now we're able to plan
projects within budget out of better
quality right we will talk about the
planning Excel we will learn about a
project plan and how we make an
effective at Microsoft before we begin
let's have all the topics we'll be
covering today first you will see the
basics of a project plan then we will
take process of project management and
why should one refer to Microsoft Excel
apart from this we will learn about how
to make a gunshot we will check some
Microsoft Excel glitch so without any
further Ado let's get started let's see
what is Project plan the basic thing
that is needed to execute according to
product management book of knowledge a
project it defines an approved
collaborative document that buys a team
during project execution and project
control when you're making a project
plan every plan must answer several
questions for us these questions are
like what are we expecting a project to
deliver how are we expecting to get our
deliverables within the desired time who
all will be a part of a project and what
tasks they will have a project when will
the restart and then expected to end
that is the deadline of the product now
let us learn about which Management in
Excel micro pixel is foreign
templates in Excel that help us to have
an effective distribution of projector
you will be checking several project
management templates towards the end of
this video now let's have a look at the
process of making a Gantt chart in Excel
before we begin this it's important we
know what is a Gantt chart a Gantt chart
is like horizontal chart that is
Resource Management with the hip chart
the date the end and the dependency
function helps with auditing and
monitoring different tasks in a project
now let's have a look at these steps
that will help us
we have several rows in columns like
here we have three columns in the First
Column we have the tasks the second we
have started
start date is already in the entry
section then in the dialog box that
appears type tenure in the series name
and click on the Range selection icon
that's shown in the figure that's like
the relevant data okay now we can see a
bar graph that has two colors honestly
this application of the tasks the fourth
step we have is ADD description to the
Chart now we will open the box again and
in that box we will select the editor
shown in the figure then we will see the
tasks as we had selected integration of
last before and we can also tasks have
appeared towards the left side chart the
fair and remarkable step will help us
bar graph into a Gantt chart you will
now click on the bars and say the format
series option from menu that appears
then in the format data series dialog
box we will select no filter finder
Gantt chart on the screen now in
accordance with the data that we had
entered now we see that on the left side
are in the reverse order so what we will
do next is we will click on the top
panel then go to the format Excel box
and select the categories in Reverse
production now we can find the tasks in
the right order one more thing we can
notice is Gantt chart is starting with
some other date and not with the dates
that you added so for this we will copy
the first bit in summary cell then
clicking the copy cell we will go to the
home menu to select the other box as
shown in the figure then in that drop
down menu you will select the number
option we can now find a value displayed
in the copied cell we'll copy that value
click on the dates on the chart it has
the format access dialog box opens
you'll be the value in the box that says
minimum shown in the figure as a result
we will answer the screen in the last
step making several designs change
colors and make it more positive for us
now then we know the basic steps of
being a Gantt chart I will show the
Practical video in Microsoft Excel after
step is to open Microsoft Excel and in
Microsoft Excel we will make a
projectable
the First Column will be
in task one we have 1.1 1.2 1.3 then
comes task two in task 2 we have 0.1 2.2
2.3 and 2.4 then we have task three the
task 3 we will have two subsections
then we will start with the starting
dates in start dates we'll put first
January the Task 1 1.1 will be first of
January and this will be 4th January
let's say this is 5th January then we
will put this as 11th of January and
this will be again 11th January this
will be 15th January let's put this as
17th January let this be 19 generate
last three begins on 23rd degree and the
3.2 section begins at 26 foreign
and let's say this takes 60s and it
takes four days then become two task
three mistakes eight days and let's say
60 days and three takes five days so
this is how objective is ready in the
second step we will set the entire
second column after we selected this
column we will go to insert up it is
on the chart you select select the
option in the select data social box if
I start date is already there now we'll
click on add another series
we will click on this icon and select
the entire tenure series and click on OK
so this is the bar graph that you have
now this is now intervals
now has the duration of all the tasks in
our productive now the fourth step now
it's time for us our discussion to our
Gantt chart instead of this one two
three four five plus one task two and
the sub tasks so what we will do is we
will again go to that box we will left
click on the Gantt chart select the
selected option and then you're going to
start it here we'll select the education
in the edit option you will select all
the tasks and click ok now you can see
all the tasks online towards the left of
the bar chart as we can see this is a
bar chart and not a Gantt chart the next
step we have is converting this bar
graph into Gadget so we will click on
the bars and say the format data is
option that appears here we have this
formatted simulation now you can see the
dialog box on this screen here we'll go
into the color section fill section and
then it was like no fill now you can see
the blue lines have disappeared so this
looks like an chart so now when we have
a Gantt chart on the screen we can
notice that the task here is order so
what you will do is click on these tasks
and select the format extraction here
we can see a Gantt chart is now in order
like we have a task on top and task
three at the bottom the data starting
from here to December but the dates we
have provided after January now we will
copy the cell then go on the dish box
here we go to format access we can see
minimum in this minimum we will paste
this value and press it as we present up
weekends again charts
in the last step what we can do is make
our Gantt chart more representable we
can change all of these bars we can give
them shapes and get many other things
like what we'll do is we will select one
let's say we give the color blue then
task two we will give it color green and
task 3 will give it to the black so your
subsections will give the colors of
sections as well then we come to task
2.1 this is how we can change color
pieces or apart changing colors
so this is how you can become
colors or changing the shades chart
honestly finally let's have it with
Microsoft Excel project management
microsies with each other you can
monitor the status check the progress
our project has made moving forth we
will check some important Microsoft
Excel templates the first template value
is Excel Pro review template this
template helps us have overview of the
project we have a clear understanding
all the tasks that are planned and that
are completed this hashtag managers to
measure the products of the project and
take for steps accordingly second
material check is
all expenditures
template from office timeline.com
so This Is How We Do systems
or sessions this template includes the
study the end date and the duration of
each task you also see the percentage
computer each task let's have a look as
well
so if you change any data you see again
change it for example
you can see the guy in charge changing
this is two track sessions let's look at
the fourth cell template the temperature
is
associated with the project let's have a
look at this in Excel once we can see
the Gantt chart in accordance to the
data if we change the estimated hours at
two places let's say a design review
this is how we can use the circuit
manager ID in a project move forward the
next step we will see is Excel projects
your support template this table is
having list of project deliverables and
risks associated with that process about
different crucial activities in a
project after this we have Excel miles
to the actual ones let's have a look at
this this is the Gantt chart with
respect to the data entered let's make
changes at several places in data we can
make this 22 224 you definitely go to
two and we get this fixable go to 15
September and when we make changes is
fluctuating so this is how we use
template to plan a product effectively
and efficiently yeah this was on Project
time management let's begin with the
objectives of this lesson after
completing you will be able to Define
project time management explain project
schedule get data and network diagrams
identify key terms using project I
managed describe the budget time
management processes explain various
skill network analysis techniques in
next screen what is typical project
management process map there are seven
processes in project management group
into 10 nunch areas and mapped to five
process groups in this lesson we will
look at the third knowledge area that is
Project time management and its
processes let's begin with the first
talk of this lesson project time
management the course of project time
management is assured that projects get
completed on site this knowledge area is
primarily concerned with building a
project schedule and ensuring that
project both as perted reschedule if
there is need to change the pocket
schedule the change should happen by
following a proper chain control
procedure others are used a PMP
examination is schedule management plan
simple management plan is part of the
project match plan and has information
on the plant project symbol and its
management and control let's discuss the
Key activities project time management
in the next meeting the Key activities
that are part of adjustment management
include identifying activities
estimating time and resources and
switching equities it's important to
type a list of activities that would be
a part of the project next an estimation
of time resources required for
completing the identified activities
done finally these activities need to be
sequenced as per dividencies in next
three let's discuss private schedule
projects it'll work as the time
Dimension budget plan and has
information like the project would start
with each of the project activities
would happen in what word project
activities would have one project would
be completed Etc usually Software System
is used to develop the private schedule
product team and interest activities and
software as well as defenses and
software can boost project schedule as
input Microsoft Project is multiple used
for projects it developed generally
project schedule is considered similar
to project management plan project
management plan is different from
Project schedule project Mission plan
now has information about the project
schedule also other important project
related plans like Risk Management Plan
cost match plan Etc let us focus on get
chart in the next screen
guest chart is a type of art chart that
illustrates my schedule it shows the
dependencies between the project
activities as well as the percent
condition a sample chart is shown on
screen two summary elements of word
breakdown structure are depicted to
depict those elements there are a number
of activities under them some of these
activities have dependencies for example
entity B and C have dependency activity
C can start only when activity B the
chart gives you an idea about
interesting activities are planned to
finish and when the overall WBS element
will have delivered create tasks and
work with the Gantt chart this will make
ancient chart-based questions easy and
fun in extreme let's understand
relationships that exist among project
activities Network diagram is extendedly
used in the project time management
knowledge area to plot The Entity
dependencies this is a grapple
representation of product database in
the form of a network there are two ways
to draw a network diagram in precedence
Library model PDM or activity on node
Aon boxes resin activities any arrows
and eight dependency this type of
network can have all four times
relationships between activities in
Arrow diagramming model ADM or activity
the arrows represent activities
relationships and sequences can inferred
from the direction the arrows and
linkages between the activities and such
text Network only finish to start
relationships can shown
such diagrams may need to make use of
dumb activities to indicate some
tendency between activities there any
questions based on that word diagram so
create and work with the diagram the
battery Network diagram based questions
easy and fun the next screen let us look
at Network diagram a solidwork diagram
is shown on the screen activities A and
C can happen in parallel B and D require
both A and C deplete whereas e requires
both B and B to be activity on Arrow
Network diagram makes use of hammock
activities they are used to show a
comprehensive summary activity combining
some other cities underneath for control
and Reporting purposes the next screen
let us look at a few important terms in
time management
when a successor activity can start
before the processor activity can
complete is considered lead for example
you can start bearing the test
environment two weeks so when the build
activity finishes when the success
directory has to wait for a few days
after the predecessor activity has been
completed is considered like for example
one needs away for two days for
foundation to settle before work on the
pillars for the next four stars both way
planning is an irritify technique in
restored to be accomplishment return is
planned in detail while working the
future is planned at a higher level is a
form of progressive illusion and context
of estimating techniques a novice
estimating is based on the previous
project pattern if the last five similar
projects took six months complete the
next one will also hit six months this
technique employs extra judgment another
estimating technique is parametric
estimating this technique uses a
mathematical model to calculate project
time for activity based on the
historical records from previous
projects and other information a few
kind of parameters are identified based
on previous project data and the
parameter is used to predict the time
required to complete the next activity
or project for example you can normally
complete 10 kilometers of high
construction Lanes a week effort is the
total amount of work required to
complete the activity duration is the
amount of time it takes in terms of
elapsed or calendar days if you have an
activity requires 10 people to work for
IDs the total effort is 50 days but the
duration is only five days in the next
stream let's look at the projectile
management processes there are seven
budget time and processes they aren't
plan schedule management define
activities sequence activities estimate
activity resources estimate activity
versions about schedule and control
schedule the first successes are
executed during the planning process
group the other goal of these planning
processes is to develop project schedule
the seventh and the last process is a
part of the monitoring and controlling
process group the next two screens let
us discuss these processes in detail
we'll begin with plan schedule
management
is process establishing policies
procedures and documentation for
planning developing energy executing and
controlling the project schedule it
launched the planning process group let
us look at the inputs to the process the
project management plan provide
unsubsidiary plans and will guide the
schedule planning activities on Project
the project Charter provides an overall
context and a high-level product and
project description which might
determine the approach for schedule
management few products might have Skip
and constraint for example projects
analytics 2016 should complete at the
same time
Enterprise environment factors provide
organizational context to the project
including the culture of your position
the infrastructure like selling systems
available keeper cell and so on
organization process assets provide
inputs such as policies and procedures
templates past performance data
assessments historical integration and
knowledge base now let's look at tools
and techniques in this process expert
judgment refers to input received from
knowledgeable and experienced resources
expert can drop into previous
experiences the proper approach to
govern a schedule on a project
meetings may be organized to determine
the schedule management plan anybody
responsible for the project management
such as the project manager sponsored
customer and other stakeholders must
attend these needs several analytical
techniques are used to determine the
schedule management plan these include
their planning Bridges and philosophies
such as ruling weight planning or your
scheduling software they're allowed to
build what-ifs and study effective
Advanced scheduling techniques like
leveling fast tracking and crushing now
let's look at the outputs of this
process schedule management plan is a
component of the project management plan
that describes the criteria and
activities required to arrive at project
schedule as well as how to project may
be baselines monitored and controlled in
the next screen let's find activities
process
define activities is the process of
identifying the specifications performed
to produce the project deliverables it
belongs to the planning process group
the important input of defined
activities process is the scope Baseline
scope Baseline is a term used
collectively refer to project
deliverables constraints and assumptions
of the project in addition to the school
Baseline the other inputs in this
process are Enterprise environmental
factors organizational process assets
and schedule management plan a reason
why Enterprise environment factors is an
input to define activities is because
the organization might be using project
management software to find activities
and that may influence the activity
definition process the knowledge base
containing historical information
regarding activities lists used by
previous similar projects is a good
example of organization process asset
applied to settling the tool setting is
used in defining activities are
decomposition and really planning the
last technique is extra judgment where
the experience of project team members
used in building lists the output
process is activated list back to the
attributes and miles on this activity
list contains a list of identified
activities active attributes on
additional information about The Entity
itself Milestone a significant Point
prevented project the mouse on this
identifies all the milestones and
indicates whether the Milestone is
mandatory or optional let's move on to
the next process sequence entities
sequence activities is the process
identity and documenting relationships
among the project activities and is also
part of the planning process group for
activity and Milestone except the first
and last one is connected to or at least
one processor and one successor the
input to this processor activity list
back to the attributes and Milestone
list all these are the outputs of
divided to the process the current with
our schedule management plan and project
subsequent schedule magnify provide
guidance in terms of energy to be
employed from native scheduling
activities on Project
organization processes are also an input
to six examples because the organization
might have sometimes for scheduling
product activities the Enterprise
environmental factors relevant to this
process any scheduling tools and use
content management information systems
word conversation systems Etc and
sequencing activities is the Precedence
diagramming method
in this method yeah it's a draw a member
diagram and all different kinds of
Tendencies between the activities are
determined while determining activity
dependency it is important to identify
type of relationship or dependency
between entities your Technique is eats
and lag which is widely used responsive
entities the output process is a
projectile Network diagram which is a
graphical representation of the project
cities in a form of network which also
shows the activity dependencies while
designing the network diagram an
activists might be identified and that
would result in some of the project
abilities especially the ones that list
all the project activities in the next
screen let's look at the estimate
activity resource process after
sequencing the activities the next step
in Project time management is estimating
the resources required to accomplish
each of the identities estimated
resources process also belongs to the
blind process group your resources do
not mean only making resources but
includes all others like equipment
materials especially Etc simple
management plan is first input stable
management and provides guidance in
terms of methodology to be employed from
any of the scheduling activities on the
product s this process are an actively
list and active attributes that are the
outputs of time management process risk
editor is another input risk to the
project May influence the decisions
about resources that need to be deployed
hence risk registered is an input this
project initial activity assessments are
another input cost of resources as a
product are interrelated and infiltrator
for example the cost might be the
numbers type of resources that can be
employed or the time I detect a cost
that they need to be hurt among this the
resource counter is also an important
input because it has information about
the availability of these resources
some of the Enterprise environmental
factors that can influence estimating
Equity resources are availability
required resources within your position
the organizational process assets is
also important in input as the
organization might have standard
policies for Staffing or having
contractors on Project call these input
available for estimating activity
resources there are various techniques
used for estimating required resources
first technique is using and project in
this technique an expert in restarting
an estimating an estimate each of the
activities the next technique used is
alternative analysis in this the
activities are analyzed to identify
different ways to completing them this
is to ensure only the required resources
are assigned to each activities this
helps in resource optimization a lot of
future techniques many organizations
routinely publish their estimate data
and this could be used at any resources
Mission another technique that is
routinely used in activities meeting
which is decomposing activity further
down to understand it in more detail and
estimated level later all suggestions
are added to arrive at the aesthetic
activity in real projects one has to use
all the estimate each activities
sometimes the project management
software also helps estimating the
software assets are based on the inputs
provided to It software should only be
considered as expectable in estimation
and fully rely on its output clearly the
output of this process is the activity
resource requirements along with this
resource breakdown structure is also
repaired the resource instructors
categorization of all required resources
in various categories that is human
resources equipment raw materials Etc in
the process estimation several other
project documents may also be data for
example the resource estimates are
really collated with cost assessments
let's now move on to the next process
estimate activity durations
the next process is to estimate the
duration required complete each entities
should be done by someone with familiar
with the budget for example disability
if done by a hospital resource would
take a sign compared to muscular
resource this may vary regardless of the
resource used due to the project
requirements in addition the activity
duration should be continuously as you
move ahead with the project because the
project progresses
process are similar to one's in sequence
activity process simple manager plan is
the first input Signal Management plan
provides guidance in terms of
methodology to be employed for
maintenance for instance it makes the
information about the estimation
techniques deployed and the people who
need to be involved process activity
resource requirements is also an input
this process because resources
significantly affect the activation that
is the lower skilled resources within
more time than the iso resources the
inputs include activity list activity
attributes and resource rate down
structure resource calendars are also an
input to this process the type and skill
set of resources available to the team
make an impact of the time you take
complete activities risks to project the
English decision about the time required
to look at the entity hence risk
registered content input this process
the project that defines the constraints
assumptions affecting the project region
an example of Enterprise environmental
factor that again Federation is
organization's productivity metrics
Which selectedly experiences from
multiple projects last sentence
processes organizational process assets
now let's look at the tools and
techniques used for estimating
activations first is the exhibition
we'll be using previous projects in the
current configuration this can be used
with other Expedition techniques and
used to reconcile differences if
different techniques result in different
estimates free point estimating is a
method where free estimates are used as
a one it's part of a project management
philosophy known as program evaluation
and review technique the same activity
greases often not a steam exercise as
each activity may require model skill
sets to be applied there is important to
use group decision making techniques to
arrive at instance or at least an
estimate that is acceptable to all the
team members result analysis adds buffer
into projects scheduled may be added
percentage activation or of its number
of work periods
the actual techniques are public
assessment and parametric
the output of this process are the
actively graciousness and project
updates the activation estimates are
presented in terms of the range of
puzzle results for example that is my
two days that is a minimum eight days
and maximum 12 days in extreme let's
look into this scenario to understand
this concept letter after being problem
stick click the solution button to look
at a possible answer develop schedule is
a process of analyzing activity
sequences durations resource
requirements and constraints to create a
project schedule it goes to the planning
process group generally scheduling
software is used for developing a
schedule entering activities permissions
and resources to a schedule to generate
a schedule with plan based for
completing project settings another
project schedule is
scheduled as a task in itself and it
continues to apologize or progressives
the most of the inputs of the process
are the outputs of estimate activity
duration process they aren't risk
registered project soap Sigma project
staff signs resources Builders
organizational process ads Enterprise
environmental factors simple management
plan activity list activity attributes
project schedule Network diagrams
activity resource requirements resource
breakdown structure and activity rate
estimates various tools and techniques
are used to process simple network
analysis is a technique product schedule
employs various political techniques
such as Google path method critical
change method modeling techniques and
resource optimization techniques to
create about schedule better tools and
techniques and quickly utilizes a dual
compression and scheduling tool let's
now look at the outputs of this process
the project table consist of a minimum
plan start date and plan finish day for
each activity although project schedule
can be represented format it is more
represented correctly using either bar
charts or network diagrams or publishing
the zoo the final schedule which is the
upper developed schedule process is also
called Baseline what's the schedule is
Baseline it can be changed only through
formal Rules meeting the schedule
Baseline is one of the measures of
project success still data produced may
include number of resources key Muslims
Etc budget calendar specify the
available working days and a number of
ships each day in any hours and days
project management plan updates are a
result process many of the other
subsidiary plans of the project let me
get impacted which include cost medical
plan so management plan risk management
plan Etc this may also result in other
private documents being updated in the
next two streams let us schedule network
analysis techniques it is required
resources are available at that time
along with types of meeting activities
since schedule is cutter based
indeed generates project schedule there
are very simple Network techniques that
relies
determined based on logical resource and
other kinds of benzes between activities
why scenario analysis is trying to vary
a certain parameter to observe the
impact on the schedule for instance you
don't want to check results you put in
more resources on particular activities
situation resource opposition technique
utilization of the resources
but you would also want to build
inspection offers in case of service
which is not available
the formula for calculating standard
deviation entity at variance of energy
is also good there is a question asked
on merits the formula is important
because if a standard deviation the
whole project has been calculated the
process is to calculate the variance of
the whole project and the ticket square
root to calculate the standard deviation
object concept based questions on pert
can be expected
in that screen let's understand first
with the devil let's figure out how to
find the frequent estimation that
produces in order to draw some useful
conclusions assume that the optimistic
pessimistic and most likely study and
pretty recently using these values you
can determine the expectation and the
standard deviation as indicated now if
the causes of variation are random you
can assume that the actual values would
be distributed mean and the following
normal distribution something referred
to as the bell Turf you can use the
properties of normal distribution the
recipient probability the actual value
followed in versus
extending this launch the notion of
Sigma is retail level confidence that's
only 3.4 signs of a million the actual
value for the size range based on the
incentive level of confidence in the
outcome and determine buffers method in
that screen critical path is defined as
the longest duration path to another
diagram which determines the shortest
time to complete the project flow can be
considered as able to complete activity
for this Capital Advanced network is
also called site there are three kinds
of loot the first being the full float
which is
the second type of float is
laying the early starting successor or
successors activities
the last side is independent full which
is the amount of time that can be
delayed if all processors finish up
their latest finish dates and want to
start building immediate successors at
various subjects slightly activities are
supposed to delay activities
duration delayed activities on the
critical path is as good as delaying the
project duration positive questions
and early finish for each activity the
thought of the ideas so they represent
the overall concentration use foreign
in forward pass you neither go through
the network starting with time zero and
keep calculate each of the entities
until you reach the last activity of the
project the starting time for each
called First Art and anti which actually
is called alternately in backward pass
you travel through that word from the
project and conflict time required to
complete activity yeah this approaches
called weekly and start the activities
is the difference between the start and
restart War but there's queenly finish
and early finish both of the differences
forgot to be the same before started
being the exam in the middle of the
total for formula let's understand the
critical path calculation with an
explanatory screen
let us look at an example for a critical
path there are five activities in this
project and two paths in that work
diagram start one two four five and one
path and start one three five and is the
second path since the duration of the
path starts one two four five and is 18
days which is more than the duration of
path start one three five n the critical
path of the project is start one two
four five end let us take the three as
an example first calculate the early
shakes I think if we can start only
after Activity one since we finish
early start 53 activities
only by then therefore first start
activity three is three sister region
activities four days the Earth is three
plus four equals seven days now let's
calculate the certain League finish of
Activity 5 is 14 days the active three
happens just before active and five so
the late finish at 83 is 14 days to
calculate the late start you can
subtract the duration from the Finish
therefore now let's start back to the
three is for T minus four again in the
next three let's focus on stable
compression looking for activities in
the deal normal constituting eating
activities as well as how much each of
the activities can be crash is also
provided which activity would you crush
produce a budget Time by one day
activating the crash of the duration of
projects produced by one day as the per
unit cost of crashing activity is the
least all activities are soon to be on
the critical path here okay if you
annotate path which is not a critical
path you will not end the same time a
project in the next screen let's look
into the practice schedule compression
differential compression techniques have
different impact on the product the
impact of Fast Track leads to risk
additions increase in management
and increase amount of time to measure
we just scope on the other hand saves
costs and resources but increases
customer section otherwise by quality
saves costs and resources but increased
risk resource or increase risk in that
screen let's get into the other
techniques used in scheduling
there are several tickets that are used
in schedule projects what is everyone
else's if there's any questions like
what the particulars have ever changed
on Project well that produce a short
schedule I prefer to understand the
impact of specific changes on schedule
the goal is a schedule Monte Carlo
analysis in this method a computer
simulation becomes a project making use
of random generated values about the
probability distribution of the input
variables these two techniques are
called qualific needs resource
optimization techniques these are also
used produced and resource Limited
schedule resource optimization results
enforcing the number of resources used
in Project create a clean method this
technique develops object schedule it
takes to account will be activity and
resource dependencies next screen let's
look at the last process in project
control schedule control signal is
concerned with the term determine the
project sales change and managing the
actual changes as they occur the
participle is an important input this
process it is the actual schedule that
needs to be controlled scheduled vacancy
integration really disabled that may
need to be monitored in order to take
actions to bring the project back on
schedule project calendar describes the
working hours and base project worker
Force data has information like
objectives and which activities are
finished our project management plan and
organizational process assets the tools
and techniques are the performance
reviews perfect review is measuring
comparing and analyzing schedule forms
such as actual start and divisions per
second complete Android immigration for
work in progress virtual estimates
include resource optimization techniques
color techniques schedule impression
leads and lags scheduling tool and
project management software in the
buttons schedule process these settings
are used for the first time to develop
the project schedule whereas in control
Central process these techniques are
used to update the projects control
schedule processes
representative form of schedule variants
SV and schedule performance index SBI as
part of the control system process the
project team will generate forecasts
likely schedule or forthcoming
activities
include organizational process assets
updates change requests project
management candidates and project
diabetics in the next screen let's look
into a business
include the process required to manage
the time evolution of the project about
a single advances start and end date the
project and the project equities this
activities are signed permission and
sequence to mod holder guest charges
activities the overall project schedule
and logical task relationships while the
board dimensions about the activities
define activities estimate activity
resources estimate activations the valve
schedule and control schedule are the
same processes under project
unmanagement
generate project schedule based on the
essence of time and research
requirements we'll focus on Project cost
management
please
the track project performance identify
key Technologies used in Project Host
amendment in this screen
there are 47 questions
and the process in the next screen let's
understand concept of product cost
method project cost management and all
activities like estimating activities
and customers related to these
constitutional object activities
like planning project cost adding and
control and project relation to us
Baseline and management experiences
project activities
at high level this requires related
activities
together as one unit this unit is called
control account Wireless
foreign
let's look at each of these processes in
detail let's begin with the first
process is
easier budget and cost management is the
process of pushing the policy procedures
costs let's look at the inputs required
for this process the budget management
plan providers
description which help determine
approach to cost management principle or
some projects budget could Insurance
whereas others but it would not be a
constraint but substitute derivatives
Enterprise environmental factors provide
the organizational context to the
project including cultural position and
the infrastructure for instance and so
on organizational Supply inputs such as
policies and procedures templates
passwords data and estimates historical
region and knowledge base now let us
look at the toolsense techniques
employed in this process expert judge
the first input seat from Audible and
experience resources interesting device
and approach
experiences means maybe organized
management plan everyone responsible
projects suggested body manager
represent systems sponsored customer and
other stakeholders mustafes several
analytical techniques may be used to
determine the cost management plan at
the impact of various decisions
establishes the units of measure levels
of precision organizational processing
control must be used rules for
performance frequency monitoring costs
and very substitutes at least the
overall cost management product next
week let's go the second process under
body parts specific cost estimate cost
is the population resources required to
complete the object activity is
estimated
team gets more information the activity
cost estimation to change let's look at
the inputs of this process stop Baseline
is the most important input as it
details out the projects along with that
project schedule is also important
resources require the budget it is
a resource management plan which is
important in approximately
Resource Management knowledge area risk
register is also an input because risk
mitigation positive considering cost
money more information on risk and
effect in the project will be looked at
the tail in Risk Management another
input Enterprise
positional context to the project
organization process asset is listed as
an input as what positions set of
prostitution policies
and techniques used in the process
expertise
I'll give you that have been now
specifically used to estimate budget
costs for example a budget requirement
through suppliers
quotations
exercise
may result in updates to other aspects
of the project for example risk time
Etc
includes authorized budgets that
excludes management results
there are various tools and technicians
historical relationships are used to
predict the total project cost using
mathematical model this is similar to
another estimate or a metrics method
funding the conciliation technique is
used to show the cost of project is
budget or statensity
budget over a period let's use a measure
Monitor and control overall cost once a
project foreign
for that work actual cost is cost
incurred in order
to complete this expected cost to finish
all the remaining project
worked supplies or deficit at the end of
the project all the parameters in terms
of cost is a scenario based questions
that have been completed at the point of
Time
Zero and one for example implies that 80
cents
next parameter is
there are different ways of calculating
the AC value the Magnus depends on how
the constitutes
before the start of PMP exam please make
a note of forms of earn value technique
in the next screen listen to a business
concept Banner after reading the problem
segment click the solution button to
look at a possible answer let's take
example of a software on the project
there are four faces and he Chase takes
a month to complete and is expected cost
ten thousand dollars this is fine to be
completed steps of the project three is
surprised in the table regardless
definition is complete actual spending
on this is thousand dollars aperture and
designs on and actual spending on this
is twelve thousand dollars development
and unit testing is only fifty percent
done though it was supposed to be
pleaded by Third month it has cost nine
thousand dollars and delete system
testing and go live has not started note
Estates start time F indicates finish
time and we have indicates that it's not
finished at the end of the month based
on the above information calculate the
CV SV CPI and SPI of the project let us
look at a solution in the next screen
before we end this let's do a few
definitions that are used for your PMP
attention law admission return this
means what you put into the less you get
out it for example double number
resources working a project will not
necessarily have the time working out
the amount of money has to mess a
project and bit-to-date conversions
funny limit reactivation process of
comparing the best temperature in a
given period with funding for that large
assets produced by the company lose
value or type this called depreciation
there are two forms of appreciation
straight line and accelerated same
depreciation is taken every year versus
a corpus tag of ten thousand dollars and
useful line for 10 years is division one
thousand dollars per year at the end of
the 10th year the value of the car is
considered zero for all accounting
Pursuits excellent position depreciates
Esther than the string appreciation for
instance a car wash like a thousand
dollars three thousand to the first year
1500 that year one thousand the 30th and
so on what is covered in this lesson
there's a Greek of what was up in this
lesson
project cost management includes the
processes involved in estimating
budgeting and controlling costs so that
the project can be completed within the
approved budget
cost management plan contains details on
how to plan manage and control the cost
in relation to the Baseline and magical
variances cost estimate is educated
guess of how much an active project will
cost
but inserts the cost test and
accordingly specification of the project
under control count technique related
equities are clubbed and the customer is
one unit the four project cost minute
processes are Plan cost measurement
estimate costs control costs heard about
you management to make any potential
deviation project on the cost and or
schedule these slides this will focus on
Project quality management let's begin
the objectives
you will be able to Define quality and
Quant management according to a quality
plane quality assurance quality control
explain possibility and its categories
describe the protocol you know the
processes explain the service rules of
quality explain the next screen let us
take a quick look at the project
management process map
there are 47 processes grouped into
technology areas and maps to five
product groups in this lesson we'll look
at fifth note here that is product
quality management and its process in X3
let us understand what quality is
product manager is responsible for
Quality project color it is also
responsibility of each everyone and
objects whatever they do means product
quality expectations quality is defined
as the bridge which as an inherent
characteristics fulfills requirements
object to settings when all the project
requirements are reading the beginning
of the project on that and the resulting
product as usual user means that the
intend user can use the product with any
problem the next screen let's look at
some quality returns it is important to
discuss a few terms to understand the
concept of quality there customer
satisfaction is finance conform to
requirements and fitness for use it is
important to understand the solution in
quality and weight rate is
classification based on typical
characteristics low quality is always
problem but low rate Melody problem
better it would be a matter of choice it
is important to understand the
distinction between precision and
accuracy precision is a granularity
efficient that is how fine-grained can
you measure the income accuracy is how
much more that is how our desired view
in the next ring let us understand
concept of optimal level quality
what it comes at a cost more every
volume of the results however you can
keep on missing on increasingly there is
no limit how much a product can be
improved investment quality is
determined by all the optimal level of
quality optimal level of quality as
shown in the diagram is to be achieved
at the point of the incremental revenue
from the Improvement equals the
incremental cost is bit difficult to the
manufacturer of poised but horizontal
quality and the suitable to improve the
quality you investment I divided as
children sharing fusels and recorded
feedbacks once all these are captured
and implemented in products you lose
hairspotting and investment is increase
the manufacture becoming toys the cost
will ever increase and be complicated
for pairs to buy optimal level quality
is recently where you get maximum
repairs manufacturers now that we're
clearly concept of quality in the next
thing let's discuss while we left quad
management involves performing
activities or creating Center policies
and procedures and ensure that those
standard procedures are be followed
properly in audit it aims to show that
attributes all initial requirements and
that the specified protocol is
implemented on Project three other
activities done as part of quality
management
quality assurance and quality quality
planning is the first step equality
related activities of fighter plan while
the insurance is the next age of
implementing a quality plant and Quantum
tool is the less age when pedi checks
are done to see if project quality is
improving in this screen let us look
into the differences between the process
of voltage it is important to understand
the difference activities that come on
quality pointing partitions the quality
management plan is right this
multimation plan has standards templates
all synapses to be followed
his name is
measures results
prevention costs which is the cost like
training the team creates equipment
subdivision is appeal costs plus force
and quality like testing distress loss
answers
because of it this is a second two
internal costs it is the cost figures
that occur what is released to Cutters
for example rework and scrap the site
subdivision is external failure cost it
is cost in per failures that are after
it has been released by the team
principle liabilities work and losses
concept questions on cost of qualities
to the exam so please I know the
calories of cost quality let's look at
project Crossing process and scene there
are three projectile management
processes which the first process and
quality management is not as part of the
plan that costs perform qualities is
done as part of computing product group
and the last control quality is done and
controlling process group in next three
things let's look at each of these
processes the aim of the plan modeling
process is to identify the requirements
or standards to execute the product
effectively to achieve desired quality
qualities and creation of quality mesh
plan name of the plan quality is
identify this standard is upon process
to work or achieve result that's the
case up in the organization government
not so essential project are identified
the aim of the quality planning that is
involve determine what work needs to be
done meet those standards if adhering to
question their relevance implementing
also centers that will dependent and
rent will have positive let's look at
the input status the project plan
provides the scope and cost Baseline all
which have an implication on the quality
management plan
quote gland has a correlation with these
it might also have an impact on and be
impacted by other subsidiary management
plans such as risk management the
stakeholders of the project may have
specific requirements and Views about
the quality parameters object and these
have to be considered the risk register
gives mentioned about the risks that are
in here in the project and also those
which must be considered wealthy
activities the required budget need to
be because of planning quality related
activities because quality is all about
meetings in addition to these Enterprise
environmental factors and organization
process assets are altered as inputs a
standard can be either from organization
from government or other organizations
usually the best practice is one over a
period while the numerous projects an
example of Governors can be standards to
control air pollution by the motor
vehicles which vehicle manufacturers
must adhere to to our quality binding
first analyze the best versus the costs
I mean requirements next I Define cost
equality and confirm if I'm investment
quality just fine adding to these two
blocking hospitalizing the qualities of
so much is executed us this helps
identify the particular Quantum output
we subject which in her act as a basis
for the current project for planning
design of experiments can also be used
for cloud planning this is a statistical
way to determine what variables will
improve quality for example of
manufacturing work it can determine the
increase quantity of the wood in a
maximum impact on moving the quadration
the 76 quality tools also known as the
seven QC tools to the plan to achieve
the design ability statistical sampling
is a tool becomes relative quality plan
cannot find all the other facts boost
for example if testing is requirement
can be carried out loss out on the
entire population this sale arriving at
a representative that gives you
information on additional tools build
analysis Etc may be used to determine
multi-management plan for the project
conductive means is another important
tool the quality management in a
collaborative manner by consumers and
other stakeholders Auto management plan
is a key output of this system
ensure that offers cabins Etc checklists
are created planning used in quality
pool metrics are I suspect data that
need to be measured in the business of
project this product metrics can be cost
and schedule metrics are also designed
to follow the plan and used in quality
control one of the roles project manager
is not to manage the project also
improvises to decrease the entity's
effect when turned say timely stack
typically depressive Improvement which
actually because a project management
for example the quality management plan
the resultant updates to the cost of
resource requirements
process so please assure you have a fair
understanding concept if you take the
exam in this screen we'll discuss the
second quality management process
foreign
graphs are also called normal
distribution graph it's called as normal
distribution because any large volume of
data is plotted with the intent to track
variations would most probably be in a
bell-shaped curve the line corresponding
to the top of the bell curve is the
median of the data sample standard
deviation concept is used to measure how
far any data is from the mean standard
deviation is also called Sigma one
standard deviation from the mean covers
68 of the data Six Sigma means six
standard deviations from the mean this
would cover
99.9966 percent of the data
we will look at an example of Six Sigma
in the following screen to understand
Six Sigma let us look at an example a
tire Manufacturing Company produces 100
000 tires a day it is not possible to
verify each and every Tire manually to
ensure it is defect free instead random
sample of these manufactured tires are
taken and checked for defects assuming
that the thickness of the tires is
parameter to measured effect any tire
that has a thickness more than or less
than 10 millimeters is considered to be
defective now if you measure the actual
thickness of all 100 000 tires
manufactured daily and plot them on a
graph you get normal distribution graph
one standard deviation from the mean
covers 68 of the data meaning if the
thickness of the 100 000 tires are
plotted 68 000 of them lie within one
standard deviation above or below the
mean now if a company operates at Six
Sigma level they would ensure that all
tires that are up to six standard
deviations from the mean are defect free
therefore in such cases you can expect
only three defective tires out of a
million tires manufactured let us now
check your understanding of the topics
covered in this lesson
here is a quick recap of what was
covered in this lesson
a project is said to meet quality
expectations when all the project
requirements agreed in the beginning of
the project are met and the resulting
product is usable
quality management includes creating and
following policies and procedures that
meet the Project's defined quality needs
quality planning defines the standards
templates policies and procedures
quality assurance determines if the
project is complying with the policies
and procedures quality control measures
specific project results against
standards plan quality management
perform quality assurance and control
quality are the three project quality
management processes
seven basic quality tools are used to
plan and achieve the desired levels of
quality at Six Sigma level there would
be only three defects out of a million
units manufactured
in this lesson we will focus on project
management framework let us begin with
the objectives of this lesson
after completing this lesson you will be
able to Define project project
management program management and
portfolio management recognize the roles
of project management office identify
the project constraints and their impact
on the project explain the role of a
project manager in stakeholder
management describe different
organization structure differentiate
between a Project Life Cycle and a
product life cycle let's begin this
lesson with understanding what a project
is in the next screen
a project is a temporary Endeavor
undertaken to create a unique product
service or result for example developing
a new product service or result
constructing a building industrial plant
or infrastructure and implementing
improving or enhancing existing business
processes and procedures in the next
screen we will focus on the
characteristics of a project
a project can be distinguished based on
its characteristics the definition
describes two characteristics of a
project first it is temporary in nature
temporary here does not mean short in
duration a project can extend for long
duration based on the requirements for
example creating a new indigenous
missile defense system or country
however there is always a definite plan
start and end date for a project it
cannot go on indefinitely
secondly the project is supposed to
produce a unique output the output could
be a product service or result there can
be many common activities between two
projects but the outcome of each project
should be unique in some way or the
other now let us look at what marks the
end of a project a project ends when
either the objectives are met or the
project is terminated because the
objectives will not or cannot be met the
other reason to terminate the project
can be that the need for the output of
the project does not exist anymore
usually the sponsor of the project takes
a call about the closure of the project
it is important to differentiate Project
work from regular operational work for
example your office receptionist does
the same work every day of picking any
incoming call and directing the call to
the right person in the office this is
an ongoing repetitive work and can be
classified as operation operations
unlike projects are neither temporary
nor unique creating a new software
system to effectively track your
customer complaint can be an example of
a project when the software is
successfully developed the project
objective is met which marks the end of
the project when you start using this
software to track customer complaints
you are entering into the operations
phase
in the next screen let us now look into
project management
as defined in the pmbok guide project
management is the application of
knowledge skills and tools and
techniques applied to project activities
to meet the project requirements project
management is achieved by proper
application and integration of the 47
processes project application and
integration means these processes should
be executed in the right manner as well
as in the right order in the next screen
let us discuss how to manage a project
program management is defined as the
application of knowledge skills tools
and techniques to a program to meet the
program requirements and to obtain
benefits and control not available by
managing projects individually as
defined in pimbot guide the program is a
group of related projects which when
managed as a group in a coordinated
fashion provides benefits and control
that are not available while managing
them individually these benefits could
be from decreased risk economies of
scale improved management of
dependencies delivery of additional
capabilities optimal utilization of
shared resources and so on let us now
learn the various features of program
management
random projects cannot be grouped
together as a program the projects in a
program should be related in some way or
the other and there should be some value
added in managing them together a
project may not be a part of any program
but a program will always have projects
a project can also be executed as a
standalone project a program is designed
to deliver some strategic benefits value
to the organization these benefits can
be tangible or intangible examples of
tangible benefit could be increased
profit margins or operational cost
savings examples of intangible benefits
could be improved team morale or
building up certain competencies while a
project manager focuses relentlessly on
the Fulfillment of the Project's
requirements that is scope cost time
quality a program manager needs to focus
on ensuring that the organizational
benefits are realized in the next screen
let us understand what a portfolio is
portfolio is yet another term used along
with project and program a portfolio may
have multiple projects and programs that
are managed as a group to achieve
strategic objectives note that all
projects and programs in a portfolio may
not be necessarily interdependent or
directly related
a portfolio can be created based on the
business objectives
for example an IT service company can
have a portfolio named Japanese projects
which is formed with an aim to take over
the Japanese markets by giving more
attention to these projects within this
portfolio similar projects can be
managed as a program and all banking
projects from Japan can be managed as a
banking program
in the next screen let us discuss
portfolio management
portfolio management is the centralized
management of one or more portfolios
this includes identifying prioritizing
authorizing managing and controlling
projects programs and other related work
to achieve strategic business objectives
therefore whether the company should
have Japanese projects as portfolio or
not is decided by portfolio Management
in the next screen let us understand the
relationship between portfolios programs
and projects
the image on the screen will help you to
understand the terms portfolios programs
and projects a portfolio is part of an
organization's overall strategy it
represents a conscious decision by an
organization to invest in the portfolio
the overall objectives of a portfolio
are then cascaded down to the lower
level components the components could be
sub-portfolios programs or projects
these components can further be broken
down into smaller components for ease of
management although a project may not
contain operations a program or a
portfolio it can include other work this
other work May comprise training and
development customer support and
services
Etc if the other work has Synergy with
the overall objectives and adds to the
capability to deliver the higher level
benefits then it can be included in the
program or portfolio as well in the next
screen we will discuss project
management office
project management office or pmo is a
specific type of body or Department
within an organization pmo performs
several roles in the organization and
these can broadly be classified as
primary roles and other rules typically
the pmo may take up any one or a
combination of the three primary roles
it provides the policies methodologies
and tools and templates for managing
projects within the organization it
provides support and training in
organization on how to manage projects
and finally it provides project managers
for different ongoing projects in the
organization pmo may also help in
managing interdependencies between the
projects selecting managing and
deploying shared or dedicated project
resources if need be terminating a
project and organizing lessons alert
sessions and maintaining the project
management knowledge base for an
organization in the next screen we will
discuss how to manage the triple
constraints
any project can be done successfully if
there is no constraint on time or there
is unlimited budget available
unfortunately that is not true in real
life a project is performed within some
constraint and these constraints are
usually competing therefore if you
change one it would affect the other for
example if the project duration
increases it would lead to increase in
the project cost as well triple
constraint is a term that originally
referred to the three competing project
constraints within which the projects
are performed these constraints are cost
time and scope quality is a primary
concern for a project manager therefore
the project manager has to make
trade-offs to keep the scope cost time
quality plane and balance to achieve the
balance the project manager also needs
to manage other aspects of the project
for instance the people stakeholders
risks communication and procurements the
project manager plays the essential role
of integrating all these different
aspects of project management in the PMP
examination you can expect business
scenario based questions focusing on the
triple constraints in the next screen
let us understand who a stakeholder is
a stakeholder can be defined as the one
whose interests May positively or
negatively be affected or perceived to
be affected by the decision activity or
outcome of the project as per the
definition the project team project
manager project sponsor piano Office
customer Etc are the stakeholders of the
project a project sponsor is the one who
gives a go-ahead for a project and
provides the necessary resources to
execute the project therefore the head
of projects in the organization who
provides a green signal to start a
project and allocates required resources
to the project is the project sponsor a
project sponsor is usually somebody
placed high up in the organizational
hierarchy of the Performing organization
that is the organization in which the
work of the project is being carried out
in the next screen let us look at
stakeholder management
one of the key responsibilities of a
project manager is to manage
stakeholders a project manager has to
involve stakeholders from the beginning
of the project until the end so they are
aware of every step a project manager
has to take up specific activities for
stakeholder management identifying both
internal and external stakeholders
missing out any stakeholder can be
disastrous for project a stakeholder who
has identified toward the end of the
project may come up with his own
requirement at that stage and
incorporating them can be risky
determining stakeholder requirements
after identifying all the stakeholders
the project manager also needs to ensure
that their requirements are clearly
identified sometimes stakeholders might
themselves not know of their
requirements and it is the job of the
project manager to get them right by
doing a proper stakeholder requirement
analysis
determining stakeholder expectations
stakeholders might also have some
unstated expectations
which need to be clarified to see if it
can become a project requirement it is
again the role of the project manager to
determine the stakeholders expectation
communicating with stakeholders once all
the stated and unstated stakeholder
requirements are known the project
manager as part of stakeholder analysis
should focus on communicating them
regularly to keep stakeholders involved
in the project once you understand the
practices of stakeholder management it
will be easier for you to answer
scenario-based questions in the
examination in the next screen let us
look at the various organization
structure projects are performed in an
organization and the functioning of the
organization might affect the project
the different organization structure
types explained here are based on the
level of authority that a project
manager gets into in those organizations
in a functional type of organization the
organization is grouped by the area of
specialization within different
functional areas for instance marketing
accounting engineering Etc are
departments within the organization each
employee typically reports to a
functional manager in such types of
organization normally projects are
undertaken within the department itself
if a project requires any assistance
from another department the request
moves from the head of the requesting
Department to the head of the concern
Department the team members do their
normal departmental work in addition to
the project work the next type of
organization is projectized organization
in such organizations there are no
departments the organization's resources
mostly work on projects team members
report to a project manager the project
manager has complete control over the
resources when the project is completed
either they move on to another project
or they look for some job outside the
company they do not have a department
for themselves the third type of
organization is a matrix organization
which is a blend of functional and
projectized organizational structure a
team member belongs to a department as
well as they are part of a project team
in such organization team members have
two bosses one their department head and
the second their project manager since
there are two bosses here this type of
organization is further classified into
three different types
they are weak strong and balanced Matrix
organization
so out of the two bosses the team
members have in Matrix organization if
the project manager has more authority
over the team member such organizations
are called strong Matrix where the
functional manager has more Authority
it's a weak Matrix organization if they
both share equal Authority then it is a
balanced organization
there is another term that you might
find in the exam called type Matrix this
generally refers to a co-located team
that is a team that has been placed in
the same location to enhance their
performance in the PMP exam if there is
no mention of the organization type you
can assume it to be a matrix
organization
let us look at each of these
organization structures in detail in the
next screen let us look at functional
organization in a functional
organization the resources of the
organization are grouped by functions
sometimes called departments examples of
functions could be sales Finance
Administration manufacturing Etc each
function plays a definite role in the
organization and is headed by a
functional head or supervisor all the
resources in such an organization report
directly into their functions therefore
A salesperson would report into the
sales organizational hierarchy a
purchase executive would report into
procurement and so on you would notice
that in a functional organization the
project manager's role is not explicitly
called out when a functional
organization embarks on a project each
of the functions that are involved May
volunteer some resources to work on the
project one of these resources may end
up playing the project manager's role
the resource assignments may not even be
full-time and sometimes even a project
manager is part-time since the project
manager has no authority over any of the
resources they are dependent on the
functional heads this makes it more
challenging for the project manager to
coordinate in the team however
functional organizations provide an
opportunity for specialization for
example if a purchase executive was
reporting into the purchase Department
that executive would have exposure to
all the purchasing that happens within
the organization and has a well-defined
career path in functional organizations
project management happens at the
functional head level next let us look
at the privatized organization in the
next screen
the projectized organization has all the
resources aligned around projects the
project managers have complete control
over the resources working on their
projects the biggest advantage of the
privatized organization is that the
resources have loyalty to their projects
and project execution becomes easier
this kind of structure is suitable for
organizations whose work is in the
nature of projects there are few
disadvantages in this structure as well
firstly the role of the resource is over
once the project is completed secondly
highly specialized roles within a
project may not be fully occupied all
the time for example a purchase
executive may have worked for selected
periods on a project while purchase
activities are going on however for the
rest of the period their capability may
not be optimally utilized there is less
scope for functional specialization as
the project boundaries limit the kind of
work for the resources each project
manager is in charge of project and its
resources
next let us look at the Matrix
organization
in a matrix organization the resources
report to the functional managers and
are managed by the project managers as
well there might even be a function that
represents all the project managers in
the organization which provides project
management expertise The Matrix
structure has three variants commonly
referred to as weak balanced and strong
in a weak Matrix the authority of the
project manager is the weakest and
strongest in a strong Matrix structure
the titles given to project managers and
functional or weak Matrix organizations
are project expediter or project
coordinator they would be called project
managers in a balanced or strong Matrix
structure and have slightly more
authority over the time of the team
members the advantage of the Matrix
structure is that resources can be
optimally utilized while preserving the
capacity of the project managers to get
projects executed efficiently resources
can specialize in their functions and
have stability in their careers also
contribute to the projects at the same
time potentially the disadvantage of
Matrix organization is that the
communication overhead increases
significantly this is because every
resource in the organization belongs
into a project and into a function
leading to a dual reporting structure in
a matrix organization project management
happens at project resource level in the
next screen let us summarize the
advantages and disadvantages of
different organizational structures
each organization structure has its own
set of advantages and disadvantages the
advantage of functional organizations is
that resources may find clearly defined
career paths and Achieve specialization
and skill development in their
respective Fields it will be a flexible
Workforce since only one manager will be
responsible avoiding confusion the
disadvantage of such organization type
is that project work is hampered
Department work is always given higher
priority than the project work in
addition there is no career path in
project management which leads to lower
interest in projects in the case of the
projectized organization one of the
clear advantages is better communication
within the projects since Project work
is the only work team members are doing
it also leads to loyalty towards the
project goals the disadvantage of such
organization type is the inefficient use
of resources because every project team
has their own support function therefore
this might lead to the duplication of
effort it also leads to the resources
being left with no work since their
roles are over once the project is
completed it also hampers skill
development because the project
requirements dictate what kind of work
team members perform at different stages
on a project now let us look at the
Matrix organization it also has the
advantage of better coordination and
maximum utilization of resources however
the disadvantage is the higher potential
for conflict among the managers which
might lead to communication complexity
and overhead Management in the next
screen let us focus on the comparison on
Project lifecycle and product life cycle
project lifecycle spans the initiation
of a project until the closure of the
project the product lifecycle on the
other hand also encompasses the
operational and maintenance phases a
typical product's life cycle starts with
conception of the product and goes until
its withdrawal from the market the
withdrawal might be because it becomes
obsolete or there is no further need for
the product in the market
a product has a long life cycle a
product can require or spawn many
projects over its life for example a
project in product conception phase
could be to determine customer needs
whereas a project during product
maturity phase could be used to perform
competitive analysis typically a
product's life cycle is longer than the
Project Life Cycle a project also has
its own life cycle and this life cycle
depends upon the industry and the
organization within which the project is
being executed sometimes different
organizations within the same industry
use different life cycles
there can be questions in the exam based
on the comparison of project lifecycle
and product lifecycle so understanding
the differences will be useful in
answering such questions
in the next screen let us discuss more
on Project lifecycle
a life cycle is composed of faces each
phase represents a discrete unit of work
required to be done on the project there
are different ways of classifying
project life cycles let us first discuss
the sequential versus overlapping life
cycle in sequential phases the
subsequent phase starts only after the
previous phase has been completed
whereas in overlapping phases two or
more phases may run in parallel for some
time this could help fast tracking and
compressing the amount of time required
the other way of classifying life cycles
is how they go about the process of
planning and predictive life cycles
there is a large upfront planning phase
where all the details of scope cost time
are planned before beginning the
subsequent phases these phases then are
executed in either sequential or
overlapping modes they are suitable for
large projects where all the
requirements are likely to be known in
advance and where upfront planning
effort is required to get the necessary
approvals another feature of predictive
life cycles is that each phase May
potentially be different in the nature
of activities and may require people
with different skill sets for example
traditional software development life
cycle has phases like requirements
feasibility planning design construction
testing and transition
we will continue project life cycles in
the next screen incremental and
iterative life cycles have a short
upfront high level definition and
planning phase the product is then
developed through a series of iterations
where iteration increments or adds to
the functionality by a little all the
activities are intentionally repeated in
iterations adaptive or agile life cycles
are variants of incremental and
iterative life cycles where iteration is
very short typically two to four weeks
agile methodologies are becoming very
popular in the software development
industry and in other Industries where
the requirements are highly changeable
and frequent feedback is beneficial
let us now check your understanding of
the topics covered in this lesson here
is a quick recap of what was covered in
this lesson
project management is the application of
knowledge skills and tools and
techniques applied to project activities
to meet the project requirements
pmo provides the policies methodologies
and tools and templates for managing
projects within the organization project
manager has to integrate various project
aspects like the people stakeholders
risks communication and procurements
with the project constraints time scope
cost and quality
identifying internal and external
stakeholders determining their
requirements and communicating with them
regularly is an important role of a
project Mentor functional projectized
and Matrix are the three types of
organization structures based on the
level of authority given to the project
manager project lifecycle spans the
initiation of a project until the
closure while product lifecycle also
encompasses the operational and
maintenance phases if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you do that for free visit skillup by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
in this lesson we will focus on Project
Communications management let us begin
with the objectives of this lesson after
completing this lesson you will be able
to Define communication and project
Communications management identify the
different communication methods
technology and channels explain the
elements of a basic communication model
describe the project Communications
management processes in the next screen
let us take a quick look at the project
management process map there are 47
processes and project management grouped
into 10 knowledge areas and mapped into
five process groups in this lesson we
will look at the seventh knowledge area
that is Project Communications
management and its processes in the next
screen let us understand communication
communication can be best defined as a
two-way process of exchanging
information between two entities as you
can see on the screen if project is an
entity the project needs to communicate
with other entities in the organization
like project managers Senior Management
of the organization and any other
stakeholder of the project similarly
these entities may also have to
communicate with the projects the
communication between project and the
stakeholders is always two-sided project
manager is responsible for ensuring
proper communication to and from the
project in fact a project manager spends
almost 90 percent of his or her time on
communication you can now understand how
important it is for a project manager to
plan this activity well in the next
screen let us discuss communication
methods
communication can be done in two ways it
can be done written or verbal both
written as well as verbal communication
can either be formal or informal formal
means communicating by following some
basic rules whereas informal means
taking a casual approach these two
combinations result in four different
communication methods they are formal
written formal verbal informal written
and informal verbal formal written
method is used for project management
plans project Charter and over long
distance communication formal verbal
method is used during presentations
whereas informal written method is
applicable while writing notes or emails
informal verbal on the other hand is
applied during conversations you can
expect questions in the PMP exam which
require choosing a communication method
for a given situation so a fair
understanding of the communication
methods can help you score higher in the
next screen